Headphone sir.
Do I have him there?
Better lock in. I would live.
Hey Andrew. I do it. I'm good.
How are you? I'm good man. What's up,
chilling, man. Thanks for having me.
Thanks for being here. Of
course. Of course. I like.
What are you doing? Thank you.
I like a lot of things. Are you doing
a, first of all I liked that you're,
you decided to put all your
shit on Youtube. Yes. Fuck
it. Fuck it. Look, it's hard.
There's about a million
fucking comedians today, right?
There's more comedians now than ever
these off. Is that a locking door?
There's like a million comedians today.
Yeah.
And a lot of these
companies are overwhelmed.
You have no room for all these up and
coming guys that are coming up and you
know some, some guys like you are really
good and there's, they're looking,
you know, like how do you, how
do you get your shit out there?
Well it just put it out there
on Youtube. Exactly that. Yeah.
I mean everybody just said No. To me that
was a thing. So I didn't have a choice.
Well a lot of people that's happened
in the Brian Cowen right now. Right.
And then he just did his right. Posted his
thing, but he's releasing it on iTunes.
He's releasing it on all
the other platforms, but
there's no fucking room. Yeah.
It's, it's a weird thing because,
uh, I guess for me, you know, the,
the standard industry wasn't really
inviting to me even from the beginning.
So a couple of years ago I filled my
own and especially when I did it in New
York and I did the five clubs and I did
the cab rides in between and the idea
was, all right, if you don't fuck with me,
at least you can appreciate this part of
stand up that is being a New York guy.
Did you do 15 minutes sets in this place?
Oh Wow. That's cool. Yeah. So it was like,
I was like, if you love the game, yeah,
you at least we'll take a look at
this and maybe support this. Right.
And everybody said No.
Like Cecil said, no.
Whoa. And I had a show
with them, like, like Bro,
it was humbling, you know, and uh,
but I just believed in the project and
I thought it was dope. So I cut like a,
I could have 15 minute version, but
I'll tell you what I did is because, uh,
you can learn everything you would need
about standup from asking people who
don't do stand up. Really? Yeah.
Like I asked all my friends and just
people I would meet, I'll be like, well,
you watching these days and you know,
they'd say the names that we all
know and then they'd always say this,
they'd be like, uh, yeah, it was, it
was funny man, but I didn't finish it.
Everybody said that. Right. And I was
like, all right, so as too long. Yeah.
So I cut it down to 15.
I did like a 15 minute version of the
special ed for clubs and I just put it
right on to youtube.
And, um, it was weird.
I liked sold out shows that we can as
San Diego and I was never a sellout guy.
You know,
I have a few guys come out from the
podcast I do and that kind of stuff,
but it was never like a, like a
sellout, you know? And I was like,
well that's kind of weird. And then I did
a show in like Columbus, Ohio, you know,
the, the, what is it? The funny bone out
there, a great club, great club. And um,
I think we sold like 1600 tickets and
I was like, what the fuck is happening?
Like I was never, not
in Ohio, you know, and
like people are coming out and like, I
liked your thing. I was like, Oh shit,
maybe people are,
are watching this.
And I started to kind of like sit
back for a second. I was like,
why are people watching man? Maybe it's
short. And I was like, all right, fuck it.
You know what I'm gonna do? I'm going
to put a joke out a week for a year.
You know,
I got another 45 minutes left to the
special and I could probably produce some
more stand up.
I'll just put a joke out a week.
There was this singer who is doing that
and like he just put a song out a week,
his name is Russ. And I was like, all
right, that's, he's a worker. I can,
I can at least control that. I can
outwork somebody. So I'll do that. And uh,
I put the choke out for a weekend.
Like the jokes are to go and like someone
would go viral and I was like, Yo,
this is crazy. And people would come out
to shows and in my youtube guy hits me,
he goes, Yo, something weird is
happening. I go, what's up? And he goes,
when people watch a clip to
watch for two hours, I go,
do you mean like they'll just get lost in
a wormhole? And I go, so wait a minute.
So people aren't watching
an hour of stand up
on the networks because it's too long,
but they're watching two hours of mine.
I'm like, why the fuck would that
happen? And we figured out that it was,
you made the choice when you
are in control of your destiny,
right?
You invest as much time as you.
One is hitting snooze on the alarm clock
so that I'll take another eight minutes,
I'll take another eight minutes. I won't
set my alarm clock for an hour later.
Yeah, that would be irresponsible.
But I'll snooze snooze,
snooze and when people make their
own fucking choice, it was like,
it was just crazy to
see what happened man.
It's also the platform, the platform,
you people on their phones. Uh,
Netflix told me that half the people
that watch my special watch on a four
course. Absolutely. So people that are
watching phones, they're there. You're,
you're on that goddamn thing all day
long and it's way easy to flip a channel.
It's ways you just, you got that
remote in your hand anyway. Yeah,
that's a really good point. When you're
on your phone, you're going full screen.
You got to like tap it,
move it
and you don't know what's next.
I know if I turned this channels ESPN too.
Exactly. I don't know if I leave this
video, what I'm going to see next. Yeah,
100% little
bit of that.
There's a little bit of phone addiction
that contributes to a lot of views,
but people love fucking youtube.
Youtube never ends.
You could be on it for the rest of your
life and not put a dent in the content
that's on there. I mean, it's a space.
Yes. Especially if you have like me,
I got a lot of weird interests. Like you
look at like what it suggests for me,
it's like shit on the cosmos, muscle
cars, professional pool matches,
MMA. It's chaos. The archery
elk hunting and shit.
It's crazy.
Like I could never leave my fucking house,
just sit with my phone plugged in the
wall and just on my birthday and shit to
you, right? Oh yeah. And they were
like, yeah, I do want to check that out.
Soon as they did that, I, I saw this
when back when there was no suggestions.
Remember those days? Of
course, the dark day. Yeah.
Well as soon as they start suggesting
shit, I was like, oh my God, that's a,
that's a game changer. And then the next
video just automatically plays like, ah,
you got us.
Yes, it's over. It's like,
it's just right there.
You have all your access points to
it, you know? Yeah. I mean that,
that was the beauty of it. I found. It's
like, you know, with a special your fee,
you're maybe the best joke that you have
on your special to someone else is 33
minutes in.
So that guy has got a wait 33 minutes
hoping you're gonna hit that joke right on
youtube. Like if I had your special, not
cut it up to jokes on Youtube, what topic?
Not, you know, everything
under an umbrella, you know,
and you have an access point here you
have let's say six different access points
with a new special I have out now.
Right? It's, it's six different pieces.
So as a different access
point every single time,
some people might come for a Trump joke,
some people might come for a trainee
joke. It doesn't matter. Right?
So it's not the situation
where you have to go, okay,
maybe I hit 37 minutes in
this bit that I love. No,
you're going to get that bill right away.
And then you're going to go back
to the beginning and go, okay,
I'm going to watch this all
the way through. It's the
music model. Like for me,
I didn't invent anything.
I just stole it from music.
Musicians put out a single
for a reason. I, I kinda,
I like that. If you thinking about
marketing, yes. Complete, complete.
Like you and I are and way different
places with standup. Right?
Like you're one of the most
famous people in the world, right?
So you don't need to find
new people to see you.
People are going to watch your standup
because they're like, all right,
I have an intimate
relationship with this guy.
I listened to him eight hours a week and
I just want to see his standup. Right?
I'm still in marketing phase. I'm like,
how can I get New People to see me?
There's five people that should have
comedy specials now that's more,
there's five Jeff out to get lighters.
Do Rock, Chappelle, Louis [inaudible].
That's it. Everybody else
should be an acquisition face.
Why?
I don't know
both up man. I don't know. I don't buy
into that. I don't know. First of all,
I don't think that way. I never worry
about it with other people are doing.
I just don't think about it.
And then to all I concentrate on
is doing my best shit. That's it.
Right.
And once I got to a point where I was
successful enough where I didn't have to
worry about money,
it was a huge relief.
And honestly I think I started
doing my best work of course,
because then I wasn't thinking,
I didn't have any resources that were
dialed into how do I promote this and how
do I get that going? All my resources
like this bit needs something more.
I've got to figure out
how to really sell that.
I know I got to put maybe if I switched
it around and so it's all about alchemy.
Yeah. You know, it's all about
adding shit and trying to make gold.
All I'm doing is like starring in the lab,
trying to make goals.
And you love creating though.
Yeah. Well I don't have,
there's no thoughts on marketing now,
but that's,
you found that you love
creating. Yeah, for sure. I've
always loved creating. Yeah.
People. Some people don't
know that. Like some,
I feel like success teaches
you exactly what you wanted.
Like these people who blow up with
standup and never do it again. Yeah.
They never wanted to be a standup.
Right, right, right, right.
It's like if you blow up and all you're
thinking about is how do I make this toe
knuckle hair joke better? You
love the game. You're like,
I don't know.
The greatest thing that ever happened
for me was I stopped desiring things I
couldn't control. Right.
Like I realized, Oh,
I don't care about a special on HBO or
Netflix. I just wanted people to see it.
Right.
And if they see it and 10 people see it,
that's cool because I just loved making
it and if a million people see it,
that's also cool. But if anybody
sees it as gratitude, right.
Do you see what I'm saying? Like before
I was just this void, like so many,
so much of us are like comics. I was
just like trying to fill up, you know,
like I'm sure you get people asking to
be on the show and all that shit on it
all the time and like, it's just comics
trying to take fill themselves. Like,
and I was entitled Little
Fucking Brat Probably.
Why don't I have a special one on one?
I have this,
there's a lot of that going on.
It's useless bro. But I couldn't,
you know how like every rich person goes,
uh,
money doesn't make you happy and every
poor person is like, man, when I'm rich,
I'm gonna be happy. Yeah.
I feel like it's like dad,
like I needed to get a certain
amount of success for me to realize,
man,
I just love making these things.
Everybody does. It's like
everybody does. And if you don't,
if you don't mean you're,
you're either blessed or stupid.
You're like one of those things. It's,
it's either, hey, the year this guy,
this is pure, or a woman who's pure
right from the job and you just,
you're just all about creating. But
it's really just about, you know,
I was talking to shop about it,
that we were at the comedy store. We
were about to go on Sundays. I'm like,
how fun is killing killing's the most fun?
I don't understand how people
could quit this. He quit
doing comedy. Matt, how? How,
why would you quit?
I'm like got all the shit that I do.
If they said you could only do one,
I be like a comedy.
Everything else I could
just pretend I'm doing.
They know whether it's a UFC commentary,
I just sit at home and watch TV and just
talk about what someone's supposed to
be.
You can't fake it. Right. Cafe comedy,
you can fake literally everything else.
Everything else.
You can't fake Kylen.
Yeah.
You and I can have the same fucking
conversation with probably would if there
was no cameras, no people. If you and
I would just chilling in the main room,
green room with the colonies store,
we probably have the same conversation.
Facts hundred percent. Yeah. But
when you go up there, that is a,
that is a precision art form that
requires calculation and also zen like
smoothness and Alpha flow.
You got to be in the zone.
You got to be in that flow state.
You gotta be happy,
but you also gotta be focused.
Yeah, that'd be having a good time.
But concentrating on these people and,
and projecting to them and you want
them to have a good time. You know,
the whole deal is one of the best things
about this job is you're making people
feel good. Yes. You're,
you're there coming out of their house
to see you and they come out of there
feeling
better. They have a good time.
Yeah. If everything goes right,
they feel better. They, in my mom,
my mom said the exact same things that
you're very lucky you get to make people
feel good for a living ethical job.
Yes.
Like how rare is that imagining he's like
insurance guys as to like tell people
they can't get their bills paid from
their car accident because it was their
fault.
Or imagine if you like,
oh one of those big tobacco guys you
driving around or Rolls Royce knowing that
someone's on an iron lung somewhere.
Someone's, there's the lighter
knowing someone's drowning in their
own fluid. Yeah. You feel like shit,
I need to just fly me to noon.
Let me play among the stars.
It's like is bullfighting.
Yeah, that's what we do.
It's somebody said it so well he's like,
cause people used to always make the
boxing analogy and I hated that because I
used to box a little bit and like I
never at all felt that it was similar.
Like I've never heard a boxer go,
yeah this is just like stand up.
It is like a martial art in
that the truth is what works.
I'll go on that
because in martial arts if you like
the in particularly in martial arts,
not just in boxing,
boxing is a martial art,
but the only stuff that works
is the stuff that works.
And if you hit a guy and he goes
unconscious, it doesn't matter.
One of the things that I used to like
about fighting was that everybody could
hate me and I didn't care.
I didn't care.
Because when I got in there and I'm like,
I knew that I was going
to fuck that guy up.
It doesn't matter what his friend's thing.
It doesn't matter how loud,
loud his parents cheer.
I'm going to kick that dude and his head
and I'm going to separate him from his
consciousness Taco and that's just going
to happen and there's nothing you can
hate me all day long.
It doesn't matter.
But then I had to switch gears 100%
into comedy and I thought there were so
different.
And then I realized because in comedy
you have to get the people to like you,
right? You can't just have
these ideas and be unlikable.
Can't you get them to respect you?
But they got to like you. They,
I mean you can get them to respect me.
Even respect is liking you.
Like do you have to be,
someone could say one thing like there's
like the late great Brody Stevens who
just passed. If you looked
at Brody's material on paper,
some of it wasn't funny and when
you looked at it in real life,
it was some of my best material
that I ever saw anybody do. Right.
Because Brody's personality was so likable
and he was so funny on stage that you
just wanted to laugh at him. It
just, he figured out that, yeah,
it's, yeah, and when I was starting out,
I didn't have that. I was, I couldn't,
I didn't, I had a hard time making
that switch. Then once I get better,
I got better at standup. I
realize like, oh there's,
it's so similar because either it's funny
or it's not funny take either it works
or doesn't work and your job
is not like some comics get,
they get caught up in their image,
they get caught up in how they
want the audience to think of them
and they dress a certain way on purpose
because they want to project this image.
And they'll even say things on stage
that are kind of gross that they're the
only saying it because they want the
audience to think they're cool. Right.
And it gives you a little like ill,
but maybe they're good enough so
that you seal lad everybody, Eh, cds,
authenticity, illuminates all those
comics can't follow a real comic. Right.
Did you ever notice that when you
see someone who's being truthful,
he might not even be as funny,
he might not be killing as hard,
but it's so authentic that when the
comic comes next it feels like they're
reading jokes off a
paper. Right. And it's,
our bodies are keyed into like comedies
reptilian if you do it right. Right.
You know like a lot of times
people will ask like why?
Like old women can laugh at the
same jokes that I'm telling it.
Like these young people can laugh
at and then my response is always,
it's not their choice. Like I'm not
telling you jokes to your choice.
Like the daily show, Trevor Noah is
jokes about how you want the world to be.
I'm telling you jokes about how you
deep down feeling is going at your gut.
It's reptile shit.
So it's like if it's in here already,
you're going to laugh for girls,
how old you are,
regardless of how you were raised.
This is how you feel.
And I think it's why you guys love 'em
Diaz so much. Do you know what I mean?
It's like he doesn't happen to
how to not be himself. He's like,
I like, he's like a, what is
he Latino? What kind of land?
He's a Cuban Larry David.
Do you know what I mean? It's just
like, like what does Larry David,
the whole show is what if someone
was authentic 24 hours a day?
What was Patrice raw authenticity 24
hours a day and we're drawn to that in its
worst form and it's best for them,
but we're fucking drawn to that and like
there's something beautiful that that,
that's why I always use
the bullfighter analogy.
It's like the bull for me is the premise.
It's not the crowd.
The crowd is still the crowd.
It's like how close can I get to this
dangerous premise and I don't want to box
with it.
I want to dance with it.
I want it to put his nose up against
my nose and then I want to secure it,
but before I skewer it,
I want to fucking do that shit where I
click my heels and I do the Little Cape
and I'm going to entertain the fuck
out of the crowd with this dangerous
substance. That's what the fuck we
do. That's why we roll our eyes.
When we see the pandering shit, we're
like, what are you wasting this for?
Exactly the fucking superpower. Well, I
think we're in this weird time period.
You know there's an ebb and a flow to
comedy and right now it's the weirdest
airb because right now you have
this weird comedy that it's,
people are saying things that they want
the crowd to here rather than saying
things that are funny.
They're saying things to hit all these
check points of progressive thinking as
cis white male,
I believe.
I don't say that word to me.
I mean it's like shit ain't real.
It's not real.
Like the special I have on now is
called views from the sis. Yeah.
It's a playoff of Drake album
called views from the six.
But the idea is just like, yeah, he's
a straight guy views. Yeah. Yeah.
This is what the world needs right now.
Well,
you know the world needs authenticity.
Whether it's authenticity from a trans
person or authenticity from a straight
guy, the world needs someone to go
out there and say what the fuck?
They really thinking have a,
a well measured take on things and
that's what I see you're doing.
What you're doing is you're,
you're going out there,
you're expressing yourself and the great
thing about being turned down by all
these platforms as they can't censor
you. Yes. They're not going to tell you,
hey Andrew, we really like you, but um,
tranny we can't have tran. You
can't say that on our, no, why not?
Well, I was like, how come you can say
cabby but you can't say tranny. Granny.
Granny joke I have is transgender
training grandmother. Granny. It's,
yeah. How is this bad? Right out. What is
happening? We see it's kind of cute bro.
It's, we do it out of love. Yeah.
If we shorten something and add a y,
it's affectionate sort of.
What's not.
Uh,
if you pull your me talking shit
to someone to call him shorty.
Hey fucking shorty ready? Yeah.
That's longer shorty as longer.
Yeah. That's why Blackie's
wrong. Right, right.
So it's like this, the logic
is there is in trouble. Right?
SORTA Japs. What about
it? That's not good.
But Japanese cute Jap Jews.
He's talking about Japanese
people. Oh, calm the Japs first.
Yeah. Why is that bad? Well,
it's bad because that's how the soldiers
used to talk about them and the people
just talk about them during World War
II when they were at war with them.
So here's my question. What if
somebody was like, you know,
as one of the most refined cultures
and delicious cuisine that I've ever
experienced these jobs.
That's right. That,
you know, dance is the best. The spics,
these beats we dancing,
probably disagree with that.
Can fucking dance. Isn't
it intention, right?
Like is it 10? Yes. So I was
talking to this, there was a,
there,
there was a,
there's a trans chick that got upset
at the joke and she was like, you know,
she basically said to me,
she's like, how you know,
you probably wouldn't like it to if
as you were walking home at night,
someone called you trainee and then
threw a bottle at you. And I was like,
I'm out.
Respond to the negative comments.
But all I'm thinking is if you were
walking home at night and someone said
transgender and then
threw a bottle at shoe,
I think it'd be equally
upsetting. Yeah, right.
It's not what the word is.
It's like there are certain
words that are made to make you feel bad.
The n word is made specifically to
make you feel that you're a black cat.
Liked using it with your friends.
Right. And even then it is like,
you can use it however you want,
but the designation of the
word right is to make you feel,
but that's what it's designed for.
That's what it made up for.
But I think black people have successfully
taken a word that was negative and
empowered. Sure. To the point
where it's laughing fun.
Absolutely good times and bad times.
And you could use to describe
a powerful person. Yeah.
You'd use to describe an amazing
artist. An amazing athlete. Yeah.
Use it as a, yeah, it is the most
fluid word. It's unbelievable.
It's an incredible word in terms of
like its ability to be used on in all,
it's almost like the word fuck,
right? Like do you can stub your tone?
Fuck.
Or You could see a Ferrari go fuck yeah.
Do you know in Brazilian it's the
word com they use for that man. Why?
Yeah, it's whole. Huh? Paul
Ha. Okay. So like, you know,
like someone will catch a guy
in a choke and I go, Paul, hi.
Like that's a good thing. Or You fuck up
yourself, you're like, ah, Paul, hi. Yeah,
my keys Spanish and say [inaudible],
which means like mother
bitch and it's like a good,
it could be a good thing pulled Ahmad
they deal. But that makes sense.
Like mother, bitch, goddammit. But
come doesn't even make any sense.
Like I was trying to put my feeling of it.
When you come it's like
that is the sensation.
Like that was so good watching you
do that almost felt like me. Nothing.
And it could be bad in that like you Dick
Trick Gia and the fucking this girl he
been trying to avoid and then you come
and you'll be doing that is there's
regret.
What I did everybody,
but women will never understand post
nuts syndrome a syndrome because this is
something exclusive to us. Like I
don't know. I like you until I come.
That's true. Right? Yeah. Do not know
it's, and that's why it's so fucked up.
Like when you know women think we're fuck
boys who were pieces of shit is dudes.
It's like you don't get it.
I think I like you. Right.
Everything I'm saying to you, I
believe in my deck is just saying, man,
we're going to find out what we,
let's see.
And there are times where you
not and it's like, Damn. Yeah,
you realize you've made a mistake.
Especially if the woman is really into
you and you're really not into her and
you're like, oh, I made an error and
then you do feel like an asshole. Yeah.
But if you say that to them, they're
like, yeah, fucking asshole. I'm like,
I'm just being honest with you.
I got tricked by genetics. Yeah.
Why can't that be my biology?
Why can't I feel so for women,
you let me explain what this
is like. Yeah, you have this,
it's like finding out your guy was poor.
This is what it's like.
This is how I'd describe it.
Having an erection and getting excited.
It's like sitting in the backseat
of a really long bus. Okay?
And there's some other guy
up there driving the bus.
Most of the time you're driving
the bus now when your Dick is hard,
when you're dick is hard.
There's some other guy driving the
bus and all the windows are rolled
down. There's papers flying around the
horns honking time and you look at it,
life taking place through a
dirty windshield a hundred
feet away from you and
you're like,
do you even know where the fuck they're
going past the stop and your Dick's
like, just shut the fuck up
and calm down. I got this.
And then when you come,
all of a sudden the fog parts and you're
at the front of the bus holding the
wheel and you're like, what? What am I
doing here? How do they get here? Ah,
and you look down at your Dick, you mother
fucker, Bro. It's, it's being a werewolf.
Yeah,
it is being aware of,
right? Isn't that what, this is a
metaphor for this ravenous creature.
You're running around doing crazy shit
and then you wake up in the morning naked.
Yeah.
You're terrified. Covered
in blood. Yeah. Well fuck.
Sometimes. Sometimes God dammit.
What did I do? What did I do? Well, I've
got to turn myself in. Yeah, it's uh,
it's terrible. But that's one
of the reasons why, you know,
it's so hilarious when you see someone
who is a stereotypical male feminist
cause you know they barely have enough
testosterone to keep their heart beating
and they probably don't get post nuts
syndrome cause they just want everyone to
love them.
And they're in this weird state of,
you know Benedict Arnold
there being a gender traitor.
I mean it's really what's going on.
It's a lot of what it is.
There are men that want women
to be valued and see men.
There's men that want
women to have all the same,
all the same opportunities
and a quality and they want,
they want to value them as human beings.
And that's all real though. That is real.
But there's way more sneaky week fucks
that are pretending they think like this
because they know that women go, good,
good. You're on our side, you're an ally.
Come over here,
ally here in male ally.
And there are always these like weasely
little dude's with tiny hands and oh,
even if they're big,
they're like,
they're awkward and they've
had a hard time with women
and so they just shit on these men who
they feel they're in competition with.
It's a complete hater mood.
Absolutely. You've seen everything.
You see it in comedy. It's like, oh,
I can't do that type of comedy so I'm
going to make that comedy radioactive.
This is the only type of comedy that to
loud. Yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Hey that comedy is so for example,
like it doesn't have to be coffee.
It could really be any kind of situation.
It's like you're just trying to carve
out the market share, right? You're like,
Ooh, that Comey is dirty.
That's edgy, that's sexist,
bigoted sensor it sensor it.
All that's saying is I don't want to
compete with pussy with those guys.
It's a little bit of that,
but it's also like the same thing you
see with the right versus the left.
Like there's a lot of people
online from each side.
We want to censor the opinions
of the other people. For sure.
Instead of having a better opinion, that's
a punch. Shut that opinion off. Exactly.
Yeah. So it's like, and when
they don't have a better opinion,
they just make you radioactive so
they don't even have to talk to you,
your races. Hey Joe Rogan, you're
racist. You know, what do you mean?
Let's talk about, and you're
like, I don't talk to races. Ooh,
that was clever what you did.
You see what I'm saying?
I went through that like the second I had
an opinion that went against the grain
immediately.
I'm labeled as something that they
don't even have to have a dialogue with.
Right. They just shut you down. Well, oh,
you're a white supremacist. Exactly. Oh,
you're all right. Oh, you're this,
you're that. Yeah. It's, it's,
it's a simple week way
to end a conversation,
but all it does is it only works.
It's like,
it's like a magic trick.
It only works if you don't know
what they're trying to do. So how,
what percentage of the population
knows it? Right. That's,
that's a question I've been trying
to wrap my head around is like,
like you and I can sit here
and and see this all day,
but I think most people are seeking
confirmation, not information. Right?
I most people like they start out
their day going, I feel this way.
It could be right, left
central, it doesn't matter.
And then they're seeking out information
that confirms that. Right. You know what,
there's a parallel to that with what we
were talking about with standup comedy
and your career.
Because the reason why those people
seek out confirmation rather than
information, it's because they're
insecure. They're not at a good place.
But once you're in a good place,
like everything feels good.
Like say if you're in a good relationship
and you know you have a good woman in
your life and you're happy
and everything's going well,
then you see a lot of things for what
they are versus if you're in the hunt,
you're trying to get people to love you.
You know what I mean?
You don't have any exits. It's like,
I mean this is a weird segue to it,
but like I, I tried mom, I've
never did a lot of drugs,
but I tried Molly at
Bernie man, right? And um,
it was the first time that I experienced
maybe outside of like comedy,
but first time I experienced having
like extra love. Yeah. Right?
So instead of operating on a deficit
and like trying to make you laugh,
so I filled a void or like trying
to say something interesting.
So I fill the void,
I had extra and what I did with the extra,
without even realizing it is I called
my closest friends and my parents and I
just told them how special they were.
Now,
I didn't realize that until years later
that that's what you do with excess.
Right? So how do I get to
excess without drugs? Right?
The question for me was also how do I
find fulfillment in shit that is not in
other people's hands so much?
Like when we,
when we were talking to the comedy store,
like what I fucking love about the La
scene right now is that comics have
control of it,
right?
So it's like comics are pushing the
comedy culture right now and it's because
they're empowered.
You guys have money,
you guys have sustainability
with your fans. You're not going,
how am I going to get another
pilot with comedy central?
Am I going to get somebody to get here?
Of course, when the industry ran it,
comedy sucked. You guys were talking
about fucking unicycles and Shit, right?
And that's why, and that's why no,
it's true. And, and, and, and look,
we would come out from New York and
we would come out and we'd be kind of
disillusioned at the
comedy scene back here.
And maybe that was like some New York,
west coast, east coast beef or whatever.
And,
but what's funny is how to ecosystem
always balances itself because as soft as
comedy was out here, all the sudden an
ad a nowhere does show called roast.
Battle pops up is the hardest show
to heart the artist show, bro.
Like wild, insane. But
here's a perfect example.
Comedy central took that
and they have watered it.
Cut It like they would sell cocaine.
Yeah. But you're not getting a pure no,
you from Colombia. Not even remotely.
They took all the juicy stuff out,
the authenticity right up, but
it was real for a minute. Can Go.
They're still on Tuesday night and that
place gets fucking while I get sad.
What do you mean feel sad for some
people that get toasted up there?
I saw a joke. There was some kid
who's not retarded, but what is it?
A cerebral palsy. Yeah. Yeah.
And um, and, and he's up there with
his palsy and the other guy goes, ah.
He goes, he goes, you look
like your arms drew your legs.
Oh,
he's up there fucking shaking.
Oh fuck. Oh my God. He said,
he just puts your body in a blender.
No,
he looks like someone put your
Voodoo doll and a blender. Oh my God.
I was so ruthless. But that's what it
needed to balance the system. Right. Well,
it definitely helped. You know,
there's a bunch of factors,
but what roast battle is,
first of all, there's,
there's good things and bad things
about, first of all, Brian Moses,
the guy who hosted it was one of the
nicest guys on the planet earth and that
helps. And then also he says, you
know, never gets physical end.
We all hug like this, good
in that course, you know?
And then when people go after each other,
like there's,
there's a guilty pleasure to
it that doesn't exist anymore.
It's like there's a guilty pleasure to
that kind of humor. It's very hard to get,
if you're a fan of that kind of
fucking vicious, awful comedy,
it's very difficult to get anymore cause
people don't roast each other anymore.
They're afraid,
they're afraid and they're soft like this.
Like these kids are soft man and it's,
we've got to stop blaming kids.
We just got to start blaming parents.
Like my parents were hard made,
my mom's immigrant, maybe
that's what it is, she Scottish.
But like my parents were tough.
Like my mom let me punch my brother in
the face once because he like pulled my
backpack or something.
Like I remember like he like pull
my back while I was like, mom,
he pulled my backpack. Can I
just punched him? She's like,
once she just let me punch him.
Right.
And it was like for her when she grew up,
that's what brothers did.
And like people always do.
You know,
I know you have some guys come on the
show and they talk about how like it's
happening at the college level. Like we're
entitling these kids and it's like, no,
he's happening in elementary
school is when these kids,
what have my boy,
Marco pointed this out to me.
Both his parents are teachers in Rhode
Island. He's like, what happens is these,
these fucking kids complain about
their teacher in school. Right.
And when you and I were in school,
our parents would go, well yeah,
sometimes you teach and are
like you so figure it out. Yeah.
And now these kids go, well mom dead.
The teacher doesn't like people.
Will that let's switch you out of this
school. Let's switch you your teacher.
Let's get your teacher fired.
So they start thinking the
world bends around them.
Right.
And then now to shit with the colleges,
it's like I can't get into USC
and say like, Oh don't worry.
We'll figure out how to get you into USC.
That fucking college thing is nuts,
but we'll, we'll get to that. Yeah.
I want to know what do you think
is the root of the softness?
Like what is the sheriff is why? What's
the shit? I know exactly what it is.
You know when a
power is taken,
it's not given. It's
taken. You have to take it.
You have to rip it out of somebody's
fucking hands. Power, right? Yup.
And after you take power out of someone's
hands, that's the last thing you take.
It's give, right? If you
have the right constitution,
you have the right constitution for power.
What have you done with your power?
You've uplifted a comedy scene.
You've,
you do shows where your host him at the
Improv, right? That's not for you, right?
That's where comedy,
okay.
You're hosting shows that these
different places you can sell out arenas.
But you're choosing to
do shows in the city,
I'm assuming because you
understand the value of giving.
You're operating with excess
and but honestly the shows or
for me to work out to work out,
but you could do an hour. You don't
have to put other comics on it. Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
You don't have to say Schultes can
you come and do the show tonight?
You know what I mean? Like at the Improv
on Hollywood, which is sold out, sold out.
I was about to try to help promote and I
was like, does he need me to help this?
But it's like so,
so what happens is if you have
the right constitution for power,
you take and then you provide for your
people, you give back. It certainly helps.
It helps you too. People
don't realize like how helping
is addictive. Yeah. That's,
we can get to that in a
little bit, but like, yeah,
once you realize the value you get from
giving, as long as it's the right person,
yeah. Then you just can't wait. Yeah.
It's a trick and think that you should
keep it all to yourself because when you
keep it all yourself,
you feel like shit,
you're a piece of shit and you become
that weird old miser that lives in the
mansion on the top of the hill and no one
could talk to him and you're miserable.
Yeah. And you can go anywhere. No, it's
a, and everybody looks at you like you're,
that guy has got all that money. I've
got to figure out how to get his money.
And you want to be, you want to be Ali.
Ali walks around in the neighborhood,
he wants, he's dead. But when he did no
security, now he can knock anybody out.
But at the same time, if he just goes, hey
guys, give me a second. I need a little,
and he was older and he could barely walk.
He would just go everywhere.
Anywhere you want. Love them because
they recognize, man, we want to follow,
but we want to follow the worthy.
So we'll test worthiness.
You know what I'm saying?
So what happened?
Why these kids are so soft
is the king takes power.
And then raises a bitch ass son
because he never had to take shit.
Right. And he doesn't want his son to
go through what he went through. Right.
He's like, you know how hard it was to
take his power? I'm, I got one foot,
you know what I mean? I lost a foot in a
power struggle and that is, this sun is,
everything's give it to them. It's
like the spoiled print and every movie.
You hate that fucking prince.
So I think the generation that's
raising kids right now, spoiled princes,
the generation before that,
Vietnam, you know what I'm saying?
Like being understood, sacrifice, war.
They understood the investment in the
country and then the generation that came
next, which is handed shit,
hey, everything's good. We're
not, oh, we're not going to,
whoa, wars just handled over there. I
don't want to get drafted. And it's like,
I almost think we should
all be part of it, bro.
It's like a regret of mine that I didn't
do some sort of service because it's
like how you complain at all about the
country that you didn't put your life on
life form. There's a lot of countries
that have mandatory service.
If they have extreme levels of patriotism
and investment like South Korea for
example, they took a uh, Don
Young Kim on, was it a yeah,
no. Who Was it? Samsung
Junge. That's who it was.
The Korean Zombie. That's
right. That's right.
He took him out of his prime and he had
to do two years of service in the Korean
army. These Robinson basketball player
had to do that navy time. Really?
I just yo like you understand cause we're
so detached and I don't hate on people
for not realizing it because
we are detached as what we
do. Like little, you know,
some child slaves make iPhone and you
know, we were like, I just go, ah,
you can only really be connected to what's
in your world. Direct world. I'm cool.
That's life. It is what it is. There's
really no good or bad thing. She's are,
you know what I mean? So it's like
that's something we'll get to,
but it is what it is right there.
We're trying to do an ethical phone.
Remember that phone? What was that phone
call? And again, there were, there were,
there were putting together
some ethical android phone man.
Come on. Fairphone yeah, that it
wasn't fair and nobody bought it.
Fuck that shit was expensive.
It's more expensive.
They have a fair phone to pull that
bitch up. Let's see what we got.
Let's see if it could fuck with,
so I'm trying to get off the apple tit.
I told you I got this galaxy note.
You come back row,
you're going to come back bro. Beautiful.
That screen is looking at this,
but this shit is always freezing.
The Pixel pixelated. True.
That's not true. Come
on Pat. This has a pen,
a modular phone that's built to last.
What does that mean?
But you can like attach it to it.
Fondants they're built to last so you can,
oh, that's gonna break.
Definitely not waterproof.
It says batteries. Those batteries replace
the battery. Yeah, that's ridiculous.
Remember when he used to be
able to replace batteries?
He's had hopped out
the back of your phone.
Samsung galaxy like seven or some
shit. Removable battery. Android seven.
This motherfucker's got android nine.
You need to catch the fuck up. Naw, Bro.
What else? Fair materials. Look, there's
a white lady in the front. How fair.
Three black guys who were working for
what the fuck is fair about that picture?
If you're going to go fair materials,
how about you have white guys in their
fifties working in a factory and not
Chinese babies flush? Is this.
We have to acknowledge though that
like, do you know what I mean? Yo.
I mean make it fair.
Make all these people,
all these people who want to buy I
iPhones and you want to have your iPhone
built by some Asian slave.
How bout you work for a year and
upset the army you want to iPhone?
Put the time in,
but we should acknowledge that white
women really kind of our superheroes in
that way. White women. How so?
Because it's like they're the only
people who care about the environment.
The only people who care about animals.
Only people who build wells in Africa
like they're really all my friend Justin
wren builds wells in the Congo.
He's a six foot three training.
He said he's a Bella tour. Fucking
top 10 heavyweight. Ask Him who's,
who do people helping him?
It's Rebecca. No, no, no, no.
It's got a lot of women
that you work for them.
But a lot of men that worked for him too.
This is weird. Like women, they fucking,
they're getting it hard right now because
I think their tire coming at white men,
so they're looking for the next,
you know when the grease boil
and you got throw someone in it.
But like when you won't
talk about humanitarians,
like who gets fucked by more
races than white women. True.
Like this is really true.
True.
Except who gets the short end of the
stick there. Is that a penis size joke?
No.
Asian women and Asian men.
Asian men probably fuck
the smallest percentage of
different races in America at
least. I don't know how the rocket and
100%. Yeah. Yeah. They do the, yeah,
I think they have like some like Tinder,
they did something like Tinder study
that showed that that has a weird thing.
Yeah. Because to Asian women, no problem
at all. But uh, other ethnicities,
it's weird that it's not made
to size. Right. How so? Like,
like you would think that it's made to
sat like Lego tiny women would be into a
no, just like vagina would be like,
you know, I don't know. I've never,
I never thought that like Asian
pussy was that much smaller than like
studying, researching
chemical evidence, you know?
Well, you know, this doesn't
make 100% sense. Okay.
But I've met girls that were tiny
that you could not fuck hard enough.
Yeah. And it just opened up.
Yeah. But not, not just that.
It's just like they want it like
that. They want, they want savage,
they want to get fucking smashed.
Why?
Because I think they
realized that they are tiny.
They have small genes so they want to
get savaged genetics inside them so they
have survivor children. I really believe
that. I think it only makes sense.
Ah, some of the horniest girls irritated
in my life weigh about 104 lbs.
And these big brand that target
chicks want it real soft,
no nice Beta male.
They want to because they know that those
are the little girls are fucking giant
dudes making Doyle sites kid
and they get to keep going.
It's a never ending battle for
genetics, dude. It really is fun.
It's 100% it's a never
ending battle of genetics.
And if you deny girls fucking these like
Beta dude's may not did they do it for
a little while? They barely
fuck them. They always say
they have headaches. Listen,
I know a lot of Beta dudes, dudes
are headed. The girl does like,
I can't sleep.
They don't want to fuck the guys.
Dude.
I had a friend of mine who was dating a
guy like that when she was a really like
them. I just do not want to
fuck him. And I was like, wow,
cause why would you like that was rough.
I'm like, what are you going to do?
Don't fuck him, dude. It's it's
dude, it's insane, man. It's like,
I see this all the time,
like these like hardcore perceivably,
hardcore feminist chicks here.
My comedy could be the opposite of that.
And they're in the DMS, right?
Saying, I don't know why I'm here.
I swear to God. No, it's a trap house. She
could,
because I think feminism in general is
a direct result of a failure by men.
To be fair and by a failure by men,
to be actual men and to raise actual men
who treat everybody with respect that
when men are abusing women, those men
are bullies. They're, they're weak men.
The kind of man that would do that to
a woman that would be like physically
abused,
a woman that's a weak man.
That's the type of man that would eat
up a smaller man or take someone from
someone with four. Since security needs
to feel powerful, he's a bitch. Yeah,
he's a bitch. Right? The antidote for that
is to be a strong man. Right? Like the,
one of the things I've been telling people
like this is how you fix bullying in
school. Teach them how to fight, not
the bullies. I mean, not just the,
not just the victims, but the bullies
themselves. Everyone had a fight.
When they feel confidence that they can
defend themselves and it will have two
nicest fucking people in the world.
Martial artists go to martial arts gyms,
go to a Jujitsu Gym,
I'll take you there. All fucking nicest
people hugging everybody in friendly.
Then they're going to choke each other
half to death and hell five minutes and
before that they're all
fun, happy, playful.
They're so secure and outside of their,
they're so secure and relaxed.
There are different type type of person,
obviously not all of them.
Maybe there's people over the most
part. Yeah, we vary wildly, right?
But almost always to a human.
The mean ones,
whether it's mean women
or mean wet mailman, weak
women.
Women will tell you this,
that they work at an office and they've
got a female boss. That's a con.
That is one of the worst fucking cause.
You can't even fuck her. It was nothing.
You can do. Nothing you could
do to make that pitch happy.
She wants to take from you.
She wants to squeeze your blood it lease.
If you're cute and you're boss is
disgusting and he's a fucking asshole,
you could flirt with them a little bit
and you could like maybe get them to like
you more. Don't do it. Obviously
don't do that. But with a female boss,
you have to have a person to shit.
Shocking what the female boss,
not even that lot of women
don't like women. Right.
One of the things that I love more than
anything is when I talk to women and
they'll do this thing where they look
around to make sure no one's looking,
no one's around. And I go, look,
I would never say this publicly,
but some bitches are fucking crazy.
That's what we do with like racist shit.
It didn't burn.
Have that bit about like when I look
around and then you slide the thing about
these.
Yes.
Well this women feel like they've got
momentum in this little war of ideas,
right.
With the me too movement and Bill Cosby
getting arrested and r Kelly getting
arrested and Harvey Weinstein. I, in my
opinion, and I bet you think there's too,
these are good things.
Yeah.
When shitty men get put away or they
get arrested for abusing people,
whether it's their physically abusing
men or physically abusing women,
it's always good. You shouldn't
be physically abusing it.
I'm out of here. Yeah,
to beat those guys up.
I mean this is handled in the community
when we were younger, teenagers,
a bottle of blood, you know, it was rough
with this, the whatever who was rough.
Right.
And we went over there and if you were
married and Harvey Weinstein tried to
fuck your wife and she went in on an
audition and you knew that there was all
these solar,
he guards and all these fucking levels
before you got to him and your wife got
into that level and he was treating
her like shit and being mean to her and
telling her if you want
to work in this town,
you've got to suck this little
fat Dick be, it's over Harry.
That's over angry. I'm
shocked. Like someone told it.
Didn't Brad Pitt try to step
to him or something like that?
Did step to him and did he swing on him?
I don't know what he did cause you got it.
Right.
Well that's the other thing is
fucked up about this is like
there's going to be Weinstein's. Yeah.
Like these people are going to exist.
This man, they still exist. Yeah, they
still do it. Hearing about one last night,
someone was to,
I can't tell you cause I don't,
he's a television personality who is
apparently a closeted homosexual. Oh.
And he's out there and he's out there
like dude's yeah, just that home.
I don't know. He's trying really hard
and making them uncomfortable. Really?
Really? How? How well known. I don't know.
We'll talk later,
but what I'm saying,
go talk to him afterwards.
Crazy fuckers out there.
There's still rolling it old school.
They want to get caught. Gwyneth Paltrow,
V's Brad Pitt threatened to kill Harvey
Weinstein. But you've got a swag on hand,
but you got to swing on him,
Bro. You gotta leave some marks?
I believe it so well it depends on what
Harvey did versus what if he grabbed her
and did anything to her physically,
then you got to swing on him.
But if he just said something creepy
and you tell, okay, then we have word
take your fucking life,
I'll take your life.
Well I think the issue with these things
is like we know we're going to have
Weinstein's but the people
that protected Weinstein,
like the second you complain about a guy
for grope in or doing something crazy
right, that woman is doing exactly
what she's supposed to do, right?
She experienced some,
you know,
sexual assault and she's telling right
now if you silence her and shot her up,
that's where the system falls apart.
Right?
So whoever is protecting him throughout,
he got it. They got to go to right,
because she did exactly what
she was supposed to do. Right.
There's going to be Weinstein's throughout
life, unfortunately. A question.
What about the support staff? All that
many people, all of them are almost,
they're not worse cause
they're not doing it,
but they're so bad because they stripped
the person who was assaulted from
like not only equality,
but like they stripped her from,
from life in a way like they
made that person go, oh shit.
Life isn't fair and I don't have a shot.
Do you know the expression
diffusion of responsibility? It's,
it comes when there's large groups
of people that watch something,
someone's going to step in. It's like
that lady, uh, Jenna vcs or something.
Remember that there was some woman who
was getting raped in queens and she was
screaming for like 40 minutes and there
was all these neighbors around like,
yeah, I heard it, but I thought
Ted was on it. Oh Jesus,
you didn't hear about this thing, Katie,
Jenna vcs or some shit. It's an old story.
But yet everybody was like,
oh, I'll get it. It's the
same kind of thing. It's like,
well, it's just how corporations work.
So if you're working for a corporation,
the Corporation's dumping pollutants into
the river, you know, you feel like, well,
it's not my responsibility. I just
work here in accounting. You know,
like somebody else is going to
handle this right now. This is,
and I think when you,
if you're working in like the Weinstein
Company and you knew Harvey was out
there slinging Dick First of all,
and in their defense you probably
didn't know the specifics, right?
Because it's like, oh,
Harvey's a dog. He's always out
there trying to fuck. Yeah,
that's sort of normal. Like a lot
like people have to understand this.
Why does a guy like that get rich?
Why does it get rich as he
likes some patron of the arts?
Who loves creating Nabi? There's a
little bit, maybe he likes power.
If you like power,
why do you like that power?
What are you getting out of that
power once you have a Ferrari,
once you have a Mercedes, once you
have a manager, what are you getting?
You're getting pussy, pussy, pussy.
So not even about the post side.
It's about power.
It's about power so much in a shit.
Like even these pedophiles,
I don't even believe anybody's attracted
to kids. Well, they definitely are.
I don't believe it.
I believe they're attracted to power
and they're so wildly insecure that they
need to be looked at like a god and
children. When they look at you,
somebody that they admire,
something they truly look up to,
etc. They can look at you in that.
God likes state and so I don't
think it's a physical thing.
Like I was watching that abducted
in plain sight. He, he gets
whacked off by the Dad. Right?
What? You didn't see this
abducted in plain sight, bro.
Oh my God. Well this guy,
this, this pedophile destroys the whole
family bro. He is to get to the daughter.
He fucks the mom and dad who
this is insane is Netflix.
Yes. You've never, and they sent their
comedy can imagine that. Imagine jumps,
they don't censor comedy though. They
don't need a damn censored mine, not you.
You know what I'm saying there,
but it's like,
and what were the bad guys essentially,
but like my point is that is a crazy
story. It's the dynamic of power.
Like, like people say the Catholic
Church makes these people pedophilia,
pedophiles. No, they have that
thirst for power and they're going,
who in my community has that amazing
power where they're looking at him as this
godlike figure? Oh it was the
priest at our Catholic church.
That sounds like like like an evil choice.
Let me give you an alternative perspective
from psychologist cause a thing
called imprinting that happens with
young men in particular sexually.
It happens with young women as well,
but one of the things that can happen
as young men can be sexually molested by
other men when they're young and
they developed this imprinting.
The vast majority of people who are
abusers were abused themselves. Right.
And there's some horrible hijacking
of the psychology of the person.
When you're a six year old boy and some
grown man has cock in your ass, there's,
there's something about that
that it fucks with their head,
especially if it happens a lot and it
becomes a part of your life and the guys
nice to you as well and buys you things
and does things for you and then you get
older and you,
for whatever reason,
perpetrate this same har on other kids.
This is something that happens.
I don't know.
I think it's maybe, maybe it's
a combination of both, right?
Maybe you have that imprinting,
right?
And then it creates this massive
void that you need filled.
Like I think so much of
everything that we do,
everything that people do
is about filling the void.
And what is it that you need the
void filled with dictates off.
How often if you're evil,
sometimes if you're good,
there are some people that are
addicted to working out, right?
There's a void there they need to fill.
Some people are addicted to eating.
Those are the same addiction essentially.
But one is a lot better
to have than the other.
You know, it's like even with, I
mean there's even with Kanye, right?
Like I see Kanye as like this guy who's
just wildly insecure and he's trying to
justify his coolness constantly by taking
things that are not cool at all and
making them cool within a community,
within his community. Right?
So it's like everything
Kanye does like down to like,
it started with like the wasp culture. I'm
going to take like preppy, New England,
you know, polos that are pink and
shit and I'm to make that cool.
Now before the hip hop community, I mean
I grew up in New York, we were like, Yo,
that's some gay shit bro. What the fuck
is that now? Kanya where's it's like, Nah,
you gotta look fly and this, these pink
waspy things in my Khakis, whatever.
Then he takes grunge
culture, right? There's fuck,
have you seen the bright that's ripped
sweaters and all that kind of shit.
That's Seattle Nirvana Shit. But
he's like, Yo, I bet I'm so cool.
I could make it cool. Right then it takes
dad sneakers. I'm so cool. I could Yo,
you think my community loves
cool sneakers. I'm gonna
make dad sneakers. Cool.
And then what is the most uncool
thing to his community? What Trump
and what does he try to make?
Cool.
It's selfish is all about him.
Oh,
he cares is about proving that he's that
dude and he takes the most uncool thing
and puts it on his head and he's
like, Yo, I'm going to make mega cool.
And that's when people are like, at
least his community was like, Nah,
we're not gonna.
We're not going to play with that shit.
You know what I think?
I think uh,
you know how like you have something
that's supposed to take like eight volts.
You have like a charger?
Yeah,
I supposed to take like when you go
to Europe and you plug it in, right?
Well like when you plug something into
the wall like we have alternating current,
like you could have something that
takes way more amperage. Right.
I think Kanye has the wrong
plug to the universe and in a,
in a good way without motherfuckers
getting like a hundred volts all the time.
So he wants to, do you
ever talk to him? No.
I talked to him on the phone and it was
a stream of consciousness that was so
intense. I was like, okay, now I get it.
I kind of go, we had a long conversation.
He's a very nice guy.
We had a long conversation for
like 1520 minutes on the phone,
which is a long conversation
these days on the phone. Yeah.
Blew the fuck talks on the phone anymore.
He does. Yeah, but you're at your thing.
He's getting a hundred volts bro.
And he's got design going through his
head and new song lyrics and new fashion
and all this.
And I think he's just catching whatever
he can and holding onto it and waiting
through the waves to fill though.
But I don't know to fill,
there's a little bit of that.
But uh,
with him it's almost like affirming
that he's okay because he's so much
different than everybody else. Like Elon
Musk, like a lot of other people. Sure.
What's up
when he used the confederate flag,
do you know about his statements
on that? He, he said that like,
he used this in a quote.
What does he say? Oh,
react to how you want any
energy as good energy.
That confederate flag
represented slavery in a way.
That's my abstract take on
what I know about it. Right.
So I wrote the song new slaves still
like the confederate flag and made it my
flag. It's my flag. Now what are you
going to do? Not what are you going to do?
How can I take my equity
and see if I'm so dope?
But that's also his recognition that you
can take something like the n word and
use it as a positive. You could
do anything. I mean, look, if,
if black people really decide,
I used to do this bit, okay, go.
I used to as bit about a two member when
the fucking duck dynasty guy was,
he was talking a lot of shit about gay
people. It's like I don't understand it.
I don't understand. And I was like, I
don't understand yellow cars. He's a shit.
If you understand why you wasting all
your time but you better be nice because I
go,
if you keep fucking with gay people,
they're going to do something and they're
going to do something and you're not
going to be able to take it back.
Like what if gay people decided to
take over Cammo and the bit was like,
look what they did to the rainbow.
I go fucking own the rainbow. I go,
you can't wear a rainbow shirt anymore.
Everybody like bath.
They used to be leper cons and
pots of gold. Now it's dudes.
But fucking I go off to it,
I have to do is start off
every gay porn in a duck blind.
Two dudes Cammo dynasty and he get the
gayest black guy in the world in camels.
Like some about duck hunting make me haul.
And some dude just drops in out of
nowhere and pulls his camel to sucking his
dick. If they just had all
porno in camera, it's it,
it would turn cam.
I went to a gay thing and if black
people just just went whole hog on the
confederate flag, look at them. They
got Cammo wallpaper, son. Absolutely.
That's like some Annie
Liebowitz shit though. That's
like some vanity fair cover.
Nonsense organized shoot.
Very Meta. Those are weird.
Or what they're doing though. These
guys are smart. They are, by the way,
that's a shit pattern. That's a
bad cammo pattern. All ducks ducks.
Maybe it's, there's, it might be their
pattern. I bet it is a swamp. It's like,
I dunno, the gay shit is like, you know,
it's not the climate for it and
I feel you. Oh, it could be.
Don't between remember deliverance squeal
like a pig. Yes. Yeah. But that was,
that was rape. Yay. Came rape.
It's not sex. It's about power.
Well then they didn't do it right,
but they also didn't get raped.
I mean powers of part of it for sure.
But they're just going to fuck you man.
Fuck like this ain't sex bro. Just so
we're clear, bro. That guy is fucking you.
This is about sex and power. I get it.
You're not gay, but it's still suck.
People want it, man. That's the thing.
I don't know. I think the Kanye thing,
like he's just a guy who
thinks way different.
Like for whatever reasons,
the connections.
That's one of the reasons why I think
this Kim Kardashian relationship works so
well.
Okay.
There's cause like I bet she just handles
normal regular stuff and he could just
be Kanye. You know what I mean? Like
it seems like they've disease people,
different backgrounds,
different, no deaf, different,
different telling me cause it's me
because the music is phenomenal outside of
that. Okay. It's real simple. Have you
ever been locked up in a mental institute?
No. He has. Yeah. They don't just lock
you up bro. They never locked me up. Yeah.
You know my, my wife
never, I never came home.
My wife has some fucking two gorillas
that are in those lab suits that are
staring at me. I'm like,
what's with the big guys? Oh,
these big guys are going to take
you to a nice hospital. Like, sure,
we'd like to handle this quietly. What
the fuck? I'm not going with some hospital
kicks Gel. Don't just go to the
mentalist too, bro. They fucking,
they velcro. You put the mental tissue
doesn't mean that you are genius.
There's a lot of crazy people who
had just crazy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well he's definitely crazy,
but he's also,
but he's brilliant to see the work that
comes out of that crazy is genius work.
Right.
So what is it about him that allows
him to be so prolific as an artist?
You ever notice how prolific he
is? Yes. You guys constantly,
constantly banging out songs con and
there there's, he doesn't have bad albums.
No, he's, he is phenomenal at music
without a doubt. Phenomenal. At music.
This is all from this
energy that's inside of him.
He figures out how to channel that
energy and put it in good ways,
but occasionally, like it's not,
it's easy. It's not a coincidence.
It's not a coincidence that
when Kanye was on stage,
I think it was in San Jose and
he said that he didn't vote,
but if it was going to vote,
he would have voted for Trump and the
crowd went crazy and they booed the shit
out of him and then he canceled his
tour and then he went to demand mental
health institute.
All that shit happened together
because he felt the pain of this.
Then his response to
that was to double down.
His response to that was to attribute
qualities to Trump that he doesn't even
really have and so Trump in his,
in a lot of ways very wise,
the way he handles things socially,
he let Kanye coming to the White House
where that Maggot hat and just ramped up
a storm.
Kanye could define who Trump was.
He could define what loving Trump meant.
You get defined why black people should,
it should embrace Trump,
right?
He could define all this and his head
to sort of justify what went wrong with
him.
Right.
And then Trump just sits there and goes
like this and let them talk and then he
leaves. The Trump goes, what
the fuck is phone calls?
It is or it's a pizza Dick.
Suck
this shit right here.
That's it.
This is now look at that white lady
with her arms crossed in the background.
Like what in the fuck I need to know.
Or like what the fuck am I watching faith?
The blood check right there in the center.
Look at her face. She's like, okay.
What that's her face says okay,
what Kanye is like showing
Donald Trump his phone to cut.
Donald Trump's got his
lips pursed June phone.
Cushner show me some lyrics like a
devious smile and coasters phase.
Where dude up that dude.
How about the black dude sitting there
like I can't believe I have to just
face. He's like, what in the fuck
do I do when I get fired from here?
Cause I know it's coming.
I know it's coming.
Oh it glad about the dude in the back
of the beard who get the brother in the
back. He's like, man, you
gotta be fucking Shit. Me,
Ryan Gosling with the boom
mic. Oh look at that guy. Yes.
Manga all the way. He's like, Yay.
I can't wait to get on Gab and talk about
this amazing meeting of the minds to
look at his face. Who Trump
reached out to? You know,
I'm friends with his son though. Like text
friends. Really? Yeah, he's a nice guy.
He's a hunter.
We know each other through mutual
friends and one of our mutual friends who
committed suicide. Oh Shit. So I was
like, no, but he's a nice guy. I mean,
I don't agree with a lot of things that
a lot of people that I know agree with.
Yeah. I think, I think we're allowed to
be reasonable and cordial with each other.
Yes. What's the matter? What
are you laughing at? What is it?
Jim Brown was also
sitting at that luncheon.
Let him let him know.
Jim Brown used to do the early commentary
for the UFC. Really? Yeah, man.
He used to wear one of them Africa hats.
They're just like traditional African.
Yeah. He was like, he
did my job for the UFC.
Like UFC like one and two.
Are you see MMA savvy now?
He's just a dude who knows
how to fuck people up. That's
true. He's Tim Brown man.
Look at him now. The guy on his left,
uh, are left too. I left his bill.
Super Foot Wallace. That's a world
champion. Kickboxer from the 80s.
He's a legend in the kickboxing world.
There is Jim Brown. I just started, uh,
taking a couple of kickboxing classes,
kind of learn.
You've got to get framed for
it. I used to box, right.
So it's like the most hum.
First of all,
it's nice to have something to like,
want to get better at.
That has nothing to do with career. That's
really fun and you know, but uh, the,
the interesting thing about the
kicking aspect of it is, uh, when I,
when I would see guys learning how to box,
like the hook is a tough
punt for people to get right.
Because it's something you
almost have to kind of like pop,
write it and people try to throw it
instead of let your body throw it.
And that's who I am with kicks.
I feel the like the exact same person
I've been trying to teach how to throw.
It's just my body doesn't
want to let the legs go.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not sure whipping,
you know, uh, I can help you.
Yeah. I used to teach re. Yeah,
I see that you do a lot and I could
definitely help you with that. Yeah.
You know what to think the way to do
it is you do it slow, right? Yeah.
You do it slow and you don't
try to hit anything hard.
When you try to hit things hard,
then you tense up and you like fucking
Herky Jerky and goofy and key to learning
how to kick ass to do it slow. Slow. It's
a big part of it. Yeah. Yeah. It's uh,
you don't try to smash, you just try
to like get your torque. Right, right,
right. Make sure you're pivoting
off your bottom foot, you know,
the support foot as to pivot almost
with every kick basically. Yeah.
Every kick your support,
foot pivots,
support one is the one that
I'm just wondering, standing
on one, your stay. Yeah.
That standing foot has to constantly
pivot. It has to go. You asked to be,
you have to be planted. Right. But you
also have to be able to move with it.
It's like a coordinated dance.
That's why at timing and kicks is
so difficult because you got to,
you got to time it and then you got to
twist your body and at the same time,
but everything's got to work in
coordination. It's got to work in concert.
It's such a cool,
I think kickbox has gotta be the worst
marketed sport and the world. No,
that's what I said.
It's the greatest sports to me.
It's like for standout fighting.
Yeah. It's the best one.
There's a company called glory and I've
been trying to Japanese one. No, no, no.
They were American or I'm sorry, from
the Netherlands. From Holland. Um,
find out where they're from,
but they're international.
They do a lot of events here in America.
Right.
But they're on UFC fight pass and I think
they're on ESPN two what headquarters
are in Singapore? Singapore. Oh,
that's interesting. That's new.
They might've got bought out.
Couldn't move there too. Okay.
So we're trying to do some of the best
fucking fights you'll ever watch in your
life. I watched it. I have
a, in my studio, in my gym,
I have apple TV and
I'll watch 'em glory on,
it's like an app on UFC fight pass and
I'll watch it and some fucking amazing
fights because people don't know because
Dana white has a really good point.
In the 1980s with that bill super foot
walls guy was fighting. He was actually,
before that,
he was in the late the seventies into
the 80s there was a thing called Pka
karate and it was on
ESPN and it was terrible.
And it was a kickboxers who are basically
like not the best kickers and not the
best boxers. And then it was
like kind of goofy and clunky.
There's a few guys like Rick,
the Jet Rufus and some really popular
guys who were really good that we're also
doing it at the same time, but for the
most part it was just terrible to watch.
It was boring as fuck.
And then you'd watch boxing.
It's he Mike Tyson at the same time.
So Mike Tyson's on TV,
Marvin Hagler is on TV and you watch
these guys and these guys are like add a
shape and then so it tainted the, well
a little bit you're saying? Yeah, a lot.
Yeah.
It's and Moitai for whatever reason.
I mean you go to Moitai events and uh,
they're rabid and it's like a very
deep community of people that really
understand and appreciate the sport.
They'll play the Thai music and the
world of Mong Kong on their head,
they bowed or their trainer by seven
rolling elbows and smashing again legs.
And it's amazing to watch. Same thing.
Is kickboxing more or less moist?
The hardest.
It's the hardest of all of them.
More elite version of kickbox that
because it's elbows and knees and a lot of
clinch work and a lot of dumping where
they trip you and slammed me to the
ground and, and they kick you on
the way down to they'll, they'll,
they'll throw you into the ropes and
if you're still on your way down,
you get punted in the head. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, and it's legal.
It's a hoard sport, man.
It's just part as it comes.
You feel like we could
get people to get behind.
I mean even from you yet you'd have to
have some sort of an epic change in the
way we view things. But to me it's
way more exciting than football.
Like if those football players
all decided to do Moitai,
it would be better for their brains.
Right? Believe it or not, to be a fighter.
And two, you would see these elite
athletes fucking smashing each others.
Let's talk about the incredible,
I want to talk about,
because I was talking to Brendan
about this and then a and Izzy, uh,
is he came on one of my podcasts.
Um, and we were talking about when,
when are the elites, Izzy,
uh, out of Sonia. Oh Yay. Yay.
Style bender. Yeah. Style or [inaudible]
style. Then my guy, man, I love him.
He's the, he's like east,
he's a perfect example of,
of the style that is so fucking
exciting to watch. Shows his opponent.
He's fighting this dude that's the Loom
Kelvin Gastelum who is one of the elite
of the elite out there as
well. Strike Wrestler, Short,
stocky blasting, striker, good recipes.
Whistleblowing these fucking
wrestlers in the world.
They're tough as fuck.
But they have power. It's,
it's a unique thing because sometimes the
Jujitsu guys don't have power with the
hands.
When these wrestlers,
it seems like they all have power and I
was asking us and folks around in there
like it's core everything.
Yeah,
some of them but like Ben ask who is
probably one of the best wrestlers in the
sport doesn't have any power in
that sense. Cause even try. Yeah,
but he's just about getting you
to the ground fucking you up.
He just has such unbelievable
confidence and he should,
he's undefeated in his wrestling
that he just concentrates on,
absorbing whenever he can and grabbing,
what is his w I mean like maybe I'm
just such a, you know, a Newbie to this,
but like I don't understand his,
his leverage point. Like what
his, his skill, his, his,
his. He's so strong that his,
is it his grip? Like what, what is he
doing? Physical strength. It's technique.
It's an understanding of it.
You,
you to think of wrestling the
same way you would think of chess.
Like if you only know a few moves,
you're not going to beat a guy who knows
all the moves. He knows all the moves.
So once he's locked with
you, defend, you think, oh,
I'm going to stuff,
I'm going to dig in my hooks.
I'm going to palm Mullander here
and I'm going to defend here.
He knows you're going to do
that. So He's, he's shooting,
waiting for you to Palmer as you're
palming, he's switching to the inside.
He's tripping you.
He's grabbing hold of your legs and it's
really awkward way he's rolling back
because he knows your weight is going
to be going in a certain direction.
He's anticipating several steps ahead
and he has international wrestling
competition experience,
which is just next level.
He's wrestling these guys from Russia and
Iran and some of the best wrestlers in
the world. He, there's levels to
this fucking thing and level Aa,
his levels,
but the same you could
say about style bender.
See the thing about style bender
is he's an elite kickboxer.
He lost the glory middleweight title and
a very controversial decision to Jason
Wellness, who was one of the elite of the
elite, one of the best guys out there.
So style bender competed at the highest
level of one of the most difficult
combat sports in the world and in that
world he's known as a precision artist,
right? That world. He's a
technician. He's not like,
there's some guys that are just thugs.
They got a good low kick,
they get a good shell,
they throw bombs that will in a bra.
They know a few things.
They know how to pump the Double Jab and
lead and to get that inside leg kick in
style benders a different animal.
He's switching stances on you.
He's hitting you with upward elbows,
setting things up.
I notice him with the faints.
Yeah, he fucks people up.
There's a video of him.
The one when he went into God mode that
I had on my Instagram that Lawrence
Kenshoo broke down. Dude. He
fucks people up, man. Yeah, yeah.
And he fucks people up in an artistic
way to the way he picks his shots.
He just knows what you're going to do
before you know what you're going to do.
And he has several steps.
So he has that same level of skill
that Ben Astron possesses in wrestling.
He hasn't kickbox. What is more valuable
on in an openness is like right here,
like you standing in front of this dude,
she's setting them up,
looking for the moves with witness,
see how the guy responds,
and then hit watch this Sam
Senate and then walks away.
The walkaway Kao one of
the most devastating slash
psychological maneuvers of
all time.
He's a special guy,
but there's no one thing that's better.
That's the most effective form wrestling
because of the best wrestler can
dictate where the fight takes place.
The best wrestler can get ahold of a
guy and dragged him down like Khabib,
Norma Madoff, who might be
the best fighter in the world.
He's the UFC lightweight champion.
What stands out about him is that he can
get ahold of the guys and once he does,
they can't do Jack Shit about it.
He's not the best striker in the world,
but he's good enough. So you have
to be scared of him on the feet.
Cause he dropped Conor McGregor. I mean
he's, he can tag you, he can fuck you up.
He's got powers,
knock guys out.
But more importantly that's to set up
the clench and then once he gets to the
clinch, your, his, that's
it. Then you go on far ride,
you're getting slammed and then you're
getting the fuck beaten out of you on the
ground and you're getting strangled.
And that's just how it goes. But he has,
he has the full skill package, like he
can strike with you. He can submit you,
but his grappling is what allows that to
take place now with style bender style
benders grappling allows him
to stay up on the feet. See,
he's a very good grappler in terms of his
ability to get back up and his ability
to stuff to take. He's got the
sprawl. Yeah. Not just sprawl,
but he gets the fuck out of
there. He pushes your head
right. He pops his legs out
and kicks back and then he punishes
you on the way out. Take that with you.
Great distance.
It's a different,
I noticed it's different like
with the sports and involve legs,
but like you guys fight at a, at a, at
a further distance course. Yeah. Yeah.
But it also makes you susceptible
for counters in a way. Like,
like when,
when Connor was fighting Floyd,
my biggest concern for Connor
was not speed or counterpunching.
It was the distance that you're
going to be able to counter.
And when, when Connor caught Floyd
Floyd a couple times in the beginning,
I think one was the left
upper cut he called flood.
That was shocking to me because I was
surprised that he had boxing counter
punching speed. The
distance is half. Yeah.
Compared to a Kingsport. Yeah. I
would say if we're standing what, two,
three feet away from each other in
kickboxing, it's one and a half boxing.
So to cut that distance in half and still
have the counterpunching ability was
impressive. Yeah. I mean,
well he's done a lot of lower level
boxing and the gym stuff like that is when
you get up to that level,
it's a different fucking game.
Floyd Mayweather is on a completely
different planet than anybody else.
He's the greatest great of all time.
That's what I meaning like,
I think he's better at boxing then
Stephen Hawking is at astrophysics. Ha,
you might be right. Look,
he's 50 know the con.
It does count even though
probably shouldn't, right?
I mean it was a real boxing match,
but it was a guy that had zero
professional boxing matches. Uh,
but he did get tagged Connor,
Ken Punch. He's a good fighter.
He's a very good mixed
martial arts fighter.
But the thing about Floyd is that
Floyd is the best at not getting hit.
No one's better. So I've been tagged,
really tagged like three times,
four times in his whole career. I can name
five times. It should be Shane Mosley,
my Donna the end of the fourth round. Yup.
Um, the other ones are early. I'm Judah,
right. Hook actually dropped him. Sam
shooter was a wicked man. It was great.
His Dad was a kickbox. Yeah, that's
right. He came from that. A you uh,
what does the name something something,
dude, I forget his name, but all guys,
y'all do y'all do it? Yeah. And then,
uh, to Marcus Chop Chop quarterly. Oh,
that's right. I forgot in them.
Oh yeah, that's right. It was, um,
yeah, my, my pops is like a massive box
and Fannie, we still like go to Ollie's a,
he was a journalist back in the day,
used to cover like Ali and his fights and
so like, that's why I kind of came up,
you know, generationally
watching boxing. So that's
awesome. Yeah, dude, it was like,
I mean some of the best moments, you
know what else Floyd has going for him,
that the best Jujitsu guys have going
for him is that he's not physically
powerful.
Like the best Jujitsu guys are smaller
people because the smaller people learn
how to use leverage and technique
and the camp muscle things.
Whereas if you look a 250 pound gorilla,
you're some good old football
player dude. And you're like, man,
I don't want words fuck Jujitsu. Like
you don't ever have to be on your back.
Right. You know, like I was
talking to shab about Daca shops,
thinking about doing Jujitsu again,
cause I was telling him I
got a back end to a recently.
I'm really enjoying it and
like, ah, I don't know. I
go, just roll off your back man. Tell
him to be a big guy with a guard.
No big guys have gone.
It's so rare, right?
Because big guys just get little guys
on the ground and they have a nasty top
game. But then when they find themselves
on their back, a lot of them are turtles.
Ooh, they don't know what to
do. It's a technique thing.
A little guy has to learn
perfect precision technique
because they don't have
that extra size point guard in the NBA.
Floyd has we cans,
he's broken his hands many times and
even though he's capable of knocking guys
out,
it's with precision.
[inaudible] going to knock you out
like a John the beast Mugabi would or a
Francis and Ghana would or a
fucking a real power puncher.
Joe Smith.
There's guys who just fucking get you to
the cage or against the ropes had just
smash. Yeah, uncanny. Some
of these guys, it's just raw.
Power's empty and it's, Yep, he,
Floyd is all precision and he's all like,
one of the most fun things for me is
watching Floyd in the first round and
watching him take away your life.
Like I like to see him take away
a fighter's confidence. Right?
Like he knew that Moseley was going to
get off with the jab, or at least he knew,
mostly thought that he was going to get
off with the jab. And there's a moment,
even in the first round, I know he
gets tagged with that overhand right,
but there's a moment where Mosley,
Mosley pops the Left Jab and Floyd sees
it steps back slightly and then come
straight over at the right.
In that moment,
you could see Shane know that there's
nothing he can do because Floyd has time
the Jab and countered it directly.
So now your job is done. Right now
I've locked off one of your arms.
I've literally just cut it off.
Now you've got to open up with the right.
You're not going to do anything to
me. Just straight, right. I mean,
I got the Philly shell.
It's over.
It's like seeing him take pieces
away from a fighter. I just,
I love fucking Floyd man. Well, he
learned how to apologize the age too,
and his dad was a wizard.
His Dad when he was young,
fought sugar ray Leonard and of course
good fight when sugar was in his prime.
Good pedigree. Men got some good
pedigree. They know how to do it.
This smart fighters goals.
Roger Mayweather, Black Mamba.
His brother was a motherfucker man.
I used to love watching his brother fight
back in the or is a, is a uncle rather.
I used to love watches, uncle
fight. He would fight on like ABC,
like whatever television shows were having
boxing on television during the day.
Maybe it was ABC, I don't remember.
But yeah, he was like that family.
He grew up boxing and he also got to
see the things that people do wrong,
you know? And here's another thing
that Floyd has going for him.
Conditioning on the unfathomed.
He's always in tremendous shape.
Always just always in shape. I think
it's a hustle. When you see a meeting,
the mcdonalds and shit,
nothing saw that.
You think regularly? 100%
yeah, you can eat that shit.
It's just carbohydrates. It's just
bullshit. The thing about that,
like either eating sugar,
like
he'll drink a soda after a workout.
He's working out for two and a half
hours and you can take some sugar, dude.
Not only can you take some shit,
there is an argument that that kind of
sugar is not bad for you after you have a
brutal workout. Dude, when I was, when
we did this sober October challenge,
man, dude already looked
phenomenal. Fucking funny. So
I'm in New York. I was like,
Dude, you had ads are who was going
to be my biggest competition too.
Cause he lists them on hired in his face.
Like his head is just exhausted. Yeah.
He's like er, yeah. So door
to this bullshit. But his
body was fucking shredded.
Shredded. Yeah. What is this head?
Johnson. He always eats McDonald's.
He's doing while he's working
out right here. Yeah. Yeah Dude,
you can do that.
Yeah.
It's all in how much you exercise
with them now that's not surely eat,
go chat. Obviously he's eating
healthy food on top of that.
But if he feels like fucking off and
getting a big Mac, he could do that.
And there's no, no performance benefit,
right? No, but no penalty. You can do it.
So when Floyd does that, he is doing
that. Yeah. It really is eating that nuts.
It's Chad still working
out. Yeah, he does.
Just for exercise, just for fun. He
fucking loves it. 22 miles an hour.
It's his comedy.
What does he do with this these days?
So what he'll do is he'll like play
guys and like play guys in FIFA online.
He's a great follow on Twitter.
It's hilarious. Oh yeah. I follow.
It's like hit like a girl.
We'll post a picture and then he'll say,
what's wrong with the picture? It,
she'll be smoking high and be like, yeah,
but your shades at $30. Like, you know,
don't put so much money into your outfit
when the blinds in your house or $30.
Like he'll just nit pick little things
like, dude, he's hilarious. But his, um,
my guesstimation is, um, this is his
comedy, like remember you saying? Yeah.
Yeah. He used to sleep at the arena
or at least at, at the stadium.
He, when he played, he was obsessed
with it. He loved the sport.
He was talking about fighting Anderson
Silva at one time. No, no, no. He's crazy.
He's talking about finance,
football player,
coffee Anderson when he was in his prime.
I think he has martial arts skill though.
I'm not bullshitting.
I saw South Pole is actually he's got
fined him hitting the pads are hitting the
bag cause I think he has real martial
arts skill like legit martial arts.
But that's the question.
It's like when are these elite
athletes going to enter MMA? Damn.
Well they are but in small,
who's the small numbers?
Well Jon Jones is absolutely an elite
athlete but he's got a 20 inch vertical.
Uh Yeah.
How elite he did.
He's got small calves but the fact that
he has those small cows allows him to be
six foot four and 205 pounds.
Right.
You're saying if he was bottom heavy
he'd be to 50 he'd be a different weight,
which she could be,
but the way he could be a heavyweight,
he could bulk up and go up to heavyweight,
but he's got like weird calf
genetics is calves are tiny. Right.
The thing is you don't have to jump that
much in MMA and he can hit you in the
face with a flying knee.
But the what he
knows how to do and what he
can do physically in terms
of his wrestling and his
ability to close the distance and smash
guys time people. He's an elite athlete.
I think he could, he
could have done that. His,
his two brothers play NFL here he is
sparring a little bit.
He's in blue, right? Yeah.
Still can't be touched. He
says, well he's a southpaw so
let's see this
from Anderson Silva,
so he's full. Okay. Oh it's
good. Good habits. Good head
movement. Yeah, for sure.
I like the way it moves
hands down over ridiculous.
See cause the duty sparring though,
we don't know shit about him.
That guy might be terrible,
you know?
I mean the guy didn't want
to try to go to the body,
he didn't duck in and when someone's
moving their head around like that just
smashed the ribs. You go right after this
gloss of the arms. Yeah. Hit those arms.
So they tried to do with Floyd,
man. Yeah. Good luck, good luck.
Flaws in the game that no
flaws. The flaws. One thing,
it's like we're talking about with Ben
Aspirin that when a guy's a super elite
wrestler,
you think you're going to do something
but he knows you think you're going to do
something. So he does it. You
do what you were going to do,
he anticipates what you're going to do.
He has an answer to that and then you
have to regroup and he's already moving on
to step three. It's just too many
steps that he's ahead of you.
Can there be a guy like with him
that you don't engage on the ground?
Like you just kind of Jab,
stay on the outside? Yeah,
for sure. Look, Robbie Lawler, uh,
almost took Ben Aspirin out in his last
fight and it was Ben's mental toughness
and his ability to endure punishment.
Most guys would have probably gone
unconscious there. Yeah. But style bender,
like a garlic style bender would be one
of the worst fucking nightmares for a
guy like Ben ask him. Cause he's super
difficult to take down and on the feet.
He's not going to do anything stupid.
Right.
You're going to move forward and try
to grab a hold of thing and you're just
gonna eat knuckle sandwich after knuckle
sandwich and he's gonna slowly chop at
your legs walk. Yeah. And you're going
to feel that low calf kick and whack.
You're going to feel that
inside of your thigh. Shit.
You going to try to walk off the pain,
you'll switch stances cause
it starts to hurt whack.
He didn't recognize you switching stances.
He attacks the other leg.
Now both your legs are fucked up.
Yeah,
he comes down the middle with a need
of the solar plexus. Now you're hurt.
Try to play it off.
It's just a matter of doing his
game in his instyle benders game.
His game is keep the fight standing.
Fuck you up.
And then Ben aspirins, it's grab a hold of
you. Fuck you up. Drag it to the ground.
Fuck you up.
It's a matter of like who,
who's better at the weak aspect
of the other person's game, right?
Yeah. Yeah. How can I take advantage?
Crazy and no one could be the best
at everything. So some like MMA.
Math is a notoriously difficult
thing to do. Like say say if, uh,
if Jamie beats me,
but I beat you,
but you beat Jamie. Yeah.
Like that happened. But that's
what, that's Emma May math.
It's crazy. Always say that with like,
you know, styles make fights. Yeah.
But it doesn't work with Floyd.
See Him boxing that styles
make fights only go so far.
With MMA it's,
it's because the sports more
comprehensive because there's more skills,
there's more different things happen
in football compare to basketball.
Maybe there's more,
there's more tools that can be used in
here that can offset what's going on.
Yeah. Basketball, the warriors are going
to beat any team four to seven games.
It that's just going to happen. I don't
know shit about basketball or football,
so I'm just guessing.
You could be a superstar.
Like there's no one position in football
that can change the game. There's
no, I think a quarterback's over
rated and to be honest with four,
I think the most important positions
is offensive. Defensive Line. Well,
I'm always amazed at Tom Brady's
body, how regular it is. Super,
super reg, super regular, but they get it.
That whole, that team gets it. They like,
like I think Tom Praise like 15th
highest paid quarterback in the league.
It's like, right. But if you look
at elite athletes body, right,
I want to see a dude is built
like Camacho Huseman. Yes.
The UFC welterweight champion.
Yeah. That's an elite. You
look at them and go, oh,
he's not an elite athlete. Looks like
a UFC champion. He's not only that.
When you hit well, greatest
quarterback of all time, whoa.
Can't wait to see this guy without
a shirt on. Like your father.
You know what he looks like a Tom
Tom Brady. Tom Brady looks like.
Yeah. I mean, what makes
that guy so special?
Things like sometimes you know
something's going on. Yeah.
He's up here and I think,
you know,
he's got a lot of it up here and
he works hard. It's like, you know,
sometimes the greatest aren't that great
picture of him next to [inaudible].
You know,
you know what it is.
It's like sometimes having
all the natural tools is a,
to your detriment is looking at that.
Yeah, Bro. Come on. Sample. Yeah,
like a leopard. Yeah, he's ready.
Yeah. Ben aspirins similar to, yeah,
he's got a little muffins. He's got
a little muffled on a Ben aspirins.
Got even worse.
Pull up a picture of Sam down in wait
Ben Aspirin cause he doesn't want to and
he's got it like that.
I don't give a fuck.
He's,
he feels like he's so much better as a
wrestler that everybody else is fucked.
Gimme give me an image. Yeah, go
to his abdomen looking at that.
I mean, he's got the ABS, he's
got Leslie underneath that. Uh,
that's from one FC. He
looks even worse now. Yet.
Winning. Yeah, there he goes.
I mean that is not, that's Tom Brady,
man. The ideal male combat body.
You would think that's not
what the ideal body looks
like, but he'll fuck shit up. Yeah.
This is a picture of him with
Kamara Huseman there, but
he's got a shirt on. Yeah.
Ooh, Swan is insane. Lucky for him.
But like this is just some guys that like,
okay,
Francis and Ghana is a perfect example.
Some guys look like a destroyer.
They just look like a destroyer.
In Ghana it was like six, five,
200, maybe more than six. Like I think
you were saying earlier about the,
about the uh, Jujitsu, right?
Like, and it's not just in,
in this, it's an anything.
It's like sometimes the guys with all
the natural ability, they don't have the,
the work ethic to be the greatest because
it comes so easy. You know? It's like,
like we,
we all know comics that are like so funny
hanging out and they're okay on stage
and it's, I think it's be, as
comedy comes so easy to them,
they don't hit the gym.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe you need that like Jordan,
almost like sociopathic approach
to it. You know, we're like,
like we were having this
conversation earlier is like, like,
do you think Jordan's happy?
I don't think he's happy.
I remember when he was
inducted, abducted, abducted,
inducted into the hall of fame. I think
it had to tell him he was in an abducted,
in plain sight. And I was like,
well, if this guy fuck Jordan to
the goat,
do you remember when he was inducted
into the hall of fame and he was talking
about writers, he's talking
shit about writers. Fuck yeah.
He wasn't thanking his coaches and his
teammates and it's been an amazing ride
and I feel so blessed and fortunate.
No, he's still like, fuck you.
Remember when you said that?
Fuck you [inaudible] 93 your
sports illustrated issue.
You said buy shoes look shitty.
Well he has his furnace race.
Some people have, some people need
that as a furnace. Like they need that,
that competitive drive, you
know? And like, I feel like,
I feel like that happens when you
don't derive joy from what you do.
You know, like you derive joy
from that outcome. You're,
you're obsessed with outcome.
You know, like at least for me,
everything before was outcome, right? It
was like, I'm good if, if I get a special,
I'm good if I'm doing these
things or I'm good if I kill.
And the second I was stripped of
the opportunity to do those things.
I actually found like I loved creating
more and then whatever the outcome was
was extra. Does that make sense?
I think it's a happier path.
I think so too,
but I don't know if it's the path to
greatness as much as the path of the
psychopath, especially when it
comes to competitive sport percent.
Something about the best athletes.
They all miserable. How they,
they have a fucking self-loathing.
They and they also have
an ego and they have this,
this anger towards the competition.
Yeah, like if you beat them,
they would say that if you beat Jordan
and it came pool fucking hate you for
training again. Yeah, but
he needs it. He operates on,
I'm not good enough and if I beat you then
he goes, all right, I was good enough.
I don't even know if it's that he thinks
he's not good enough is that he knows
he can get you don't quit motherfucker.
I'm going to get you,
but why does he need to get you?
I Dunno.
He needs to because it's like he needs
to confirm something maybe. Right.
I need to confirm. It's constant
confirmation. I need to confirm.
Confirm that Greg confirmed.
Confirm where it's not that
he doesn't believe he's great.
It's that he wants to
confirm it constantly. It's
a little shadow of a doubt.
Yeah, I'm great. I'm great.
He's walking around, I'm great,
and there's a little voice in his head is
going, hey, you might not be that great.
How about when he played baseball?
That motherfucker want to prove
you're the hardest thing to sports.
Hitting a baseball.
It's the hardest fucking thing.
And he just jumped from basketball to
baseball and was people act like he was
trash.
He wasn't even that bad.
He hit like two 50
no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Not
a baseball card. I'm looking at.
Says he was three Oh two that
maybe what it might be for.
That's for none on one 85 out of six 15
at bats. We're talking about the heart.
This thing in sports is
hitting a fucking base.
The fact that he,
I mean there's a bunch of rumors and why
he even went into baseball in the first
place. But like that's, it's that
cycles and Campbelltown, right.
That's something we'll say is gambling.
Some people say, you know, there's,
there's a bunch of different
things. I don't want to, you know,
put it out there cause I don't know.
But like it's one of those,
I think there is a balance man.
I think that you could,
I think if you truly love what you do,
like if you love the creative aspect
and then you have high standards for
yourself, then you can achieve both. Yeah.
I think that achieving
quote unquote greatness,
um, and living with misery, I
don't think that's worth it.
No, I don't think that's
where the, for you,
it's like you got one shot at this
man, like this, this life man.
Like you got one shot at it,
try to figure it the fuck out.
And it takes time to figure the fuck out.
But it's one of those things you
can't even really explain to people.
But if you can, I'm approaching this point
in my life where like, yeah, I think I,
I get it. Does that make sense? Like how
old are you now? 35 yeah. And then like,
it's like my, my buddy explains
it like this. He's like,
there's these different phases
in life. He's like, there's,
and none of them is better or
worse than the other, but you know,
there's this vegetable phase.
We were like,
just going to work and then
coming home. Right. And, uh,
you don't think about anything.
Then there's a why phase, right?
Which is what gets us into
comedy. A lot of us, right?
We started asking him why
she supposed to do with shit.
Like why do I have to have breakfast
in the morning or like whatever it is.
We just, why. And then there's the phase,
which a lot of the discussion is on,
on this show and a lot of comedy operates
is, which is everything is and isn't,
not everything is or isn't.
Right, right, right. It's like what,
where you operate and why
people are drawn to this. Right.
And why people are drawn to,
maybe my stand up in other things is
we're shaking the foundation of the world.
We're showing that the world isn't one
way. You're not either good or bad.
Everybody and everything is both.
The maggot had is so offensive to women,
right?
Cause it stands for these
offensive things. It's like,
well what about the Viking helmet?
Like they did some fucked up shit
to women didn't today. Right?
We wear that every Sunday for Vikings
Games, then people will, all right,
so two things can be true or two
things can be false, you know,
and like that,
that place where like fucking comedy,
Liz works nuance where comedy lives
in a conversation lives, you know,
that is an amazing place.
They not everybody gets to.
Well that's what's so offensive about
progressive fake comedy is that they're
pretending the world's binaries.
It's one zero and you have to punch up.
All comedy is punching up.
I had a conversation with
this guy, wrote a book once.
There's no gray, there's no
gray. It's black or white.
So without gray, they don't even
believe there's great like you.
And I take for granted that
we understand there's gray,
we truly understand it,
we truly get it and that's why we can
have a conversation about maybe some of
the most vile things and try
to put context into it or
nuance as you were saying.
You know what I'm saying?
That conversation,
tons of people are going to write comments
on are you motherfuckers are this and
then the other side is going to go.
You might've fuckers are that.
It's so problematic that you're talking
about guest, so why? Why can we do that?
What makes us able to do that?
What do we understand about the world
that allows us to do that and how do we,
you can't tell people things. You have
to show them. How can we show that
humor? I think that's it. I think that's,
I think that's why we're the first persons
killed when a dictatorship takes over
the comedians. Yeah. The philosophers,
comedians, like anybody who goes, hey,
look at the world this way. Like get them
the fuck out of here. Stop Mocking Shit.
Stop making people think
a little bit. Well, also,
the thing about comedy is I've always
said that if you can make someone laugh
about something,
you forced them to think about it.
If you're just onstage
spouting your opinions,
like one of the real problems that I
have with a lot of what they're calling
comedy, where they're just waiting for
applause breaks and you say something,
Bro clapped her intersectional,
you know,
ideas must be approached with the same,
they're abusing condo.
Where you're doing that
they're doing is they're doing,
is there a time where they can do
whatever the fuck they want with it?
But I know the difference. It's,
it's a, it's a hack. They've like,
they figured out a way to like make
a shortcut, but it's not stand up.
It's something else.
It's like you just expressing opinions.
But if you just onstage saying
your opinions on things,
I can be in the audience.
Go on
Ma. I don't agree with that.
I have a different opinion.
But if you're on stage saying
something that makes me laugh,
even though I don't agree with your
philosophy, bull fighting. Ah, that's,
that's when it gets you,
like if you're a hardcore republican
Trump supporter and someone does a joke
about Trump that makes you fucking laugh.
You're like, God dammit, he got me.
This motherfucker got
game the second you told me.
I can't joke around about some of this.
That's what I want to joke around about.
Now you just gave me the bull and there's
this thing in bullfighting where if
you put a little bull out
there, the crowd boos. Oh right.
Because they want a dangerous book.
Fair.
Trousseau and that's how comics feel
when we see you do an easy joke.
We don't, we don't say it out loud,
but in our head we're like, yes,
they're all going to laugh at a joke
about how women are smarter than men
because there's a bunch of dudes trying
to get pussy that are at that show with
the girl they're trying to get pussy
for. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. You know,
so it's like how do
you, it's putting, it's,
it's that world where it operates in.
And then the next thing is I
think when I'm not there yet,
but I get glimpses and it's like
from nothing comes everything.
You know,
like for me,
I remember it for the show and the
comedy store in La when you walked in,
like that was crazy for me because
obviously any comic, you're,
you know, watching this show and
you're seeing and you're like, man,
it would be so cool. One day it'd be on
Joe Rogan's podcast. Right. And then,
but it was nothing I would ever ask for.
Cause I stopped asking,
I stopped feeling entitled to anything.
I just decided like when you walked in,
I was like,
this is awesome because I never
expect to see what I'm saying.
I only do the shit that I want
to do because I can control that.
And if I just worry about expecting or
wanting shit that I can't control being
miserable. Right. So and
you walked down and he did,
he did the fucking show and
you're like, you're like, hey,
I heard some good stuff and we'll
check it out. And I was like,
that's fucking unreal. And
I was overwhelmed because I
didn't ever expected shit.
And even in that moment I wouldn't ask
you to come on and I didn't care if I
didn't come on.
I didn't give a fuck because I was so
grateful that that had happened.
It was almost like I was just true to
comedy and all they wanted to do as good
comedy and the fucking,
that's how,
sorry, the universe's doors. That's it.
That's it. That's fucking it. If you,
especially in this world, the world that
we live in, if you're doing real shit,
people find out about find
out, man, I hear about you.
I heard about you through several people
and I was like, really? Oh, okay, cool.
Let me check them out. And then I saw
some of your shit online. Like Ah,
I could tell there's people
that are doing the real thing.
They're out there really doing comedy
and they're trying to make things funny
and they're talking about controversial
subjects and talk about different things
and their perspective in life and they're
worried about the industry's opinion
of him.
And what you said was so true that in
the day everybody was trying to get a
sitcom man,
and that's all they were doing.
They were doing these acts like you would
get actress who would get into comedy
just so they could put together
a seven minutes set. Yeah.
So they could get a sitcom off of it
and then they would stop doing standup.
It was a lot of that,
but that world dried up when the sitcoms
dried up and it happened right around
the time that fear factor kicked
because when fear factor kicked in,
reality TV show squashed
all these sitcoms.
And it was really funny because
some people were, it was, I had a,
an argument with a comic
about that and he's like, man,
I just think it's fucked up that you,
you're,
you're doing a reality TV show and
supporting reality TV. I go, why?
He goes because it takes jobs away from
comics that right on sitcoms. I go,
hey man, I go, first of all,
they're not writers on sitcoms.
They'd taken a job writing on sitcoms
while they're doing stand up comedy,
they're fucking comics.
Okay,
I'm taking a job making people eat
animal dicks while I'm doing calming the
differences.
I'm still doing comedy and
these motherfuckers are just
looking for some sort of
a gravy train to ride off into the sunset.
They're there.
If the show was good,
people would watch it instead of these
reality shows and then it wouldn't exist
anymore.
But there was so many bad sitcoms that
it opened the door to real housewives and
all these other things and the
next thing you know named me,
name me three set go
that are on right now.
Can, can I take it one step
further? There'll never be
another hit sitcom again.
They probably won't. It is over. It's
probably over and I'm walking around my,
the agency that I'm with a yesterday
and I'm talking to people and they don't
get it. No Bro. If I felt like
Christian Bale in the big short,
I'm just walking around or it's over.
It's over. Do you guys not know?
We need to write a show around you. I'm
like, guys, guys, guys, there's no more,
you know,
it's really over.
Do you ever look at the fucking ratings
for late night television? Okay,
it's done. It's crazy. This is
why this one's crazy. Flips up it.
You just put your clips up in your
clips up, Instagram, everything. Look,
everything that I've, that
I've done, it's for comics.
Like don't think that like you're copying
or anything like that. It's for you.
Look at the blueprint.
Yeah, copy it. Improve it.
Tell me how you improve it, but empower
yourself. That's what this is for.
The blueprint of putting
things up on, using things up.
Youtube, Instagram, Twitter,
like any and like I have a lot of comics
who reached out. Just ask questions,
but I'm here as a resource for you.
Comedy is at its best when we are helping
each other and New York doesn't get
that right now just yet. Well, there's
less opportunity. That's, that's it.
You know what happened in la, but the
sit Compton bro, you're a fucking dude.
It is so done. This is how you
know, you know how I know it's done.
What is your favorite scene in a
sitcom or, or what top five scene.
Just a scene you loved and a Sitcom.
Even though I was in a
sitcom for five years. Yeah.
And I don't really watched them,
so, okay, fair enough. Well,
I'll watch unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt,
but that's a single camera that doesn't,
it's a little different cause
there's like so audience,
but like anybody's listening right now,
right?
Like you can think of one of
your favorite scenes, right?
Try to think of how that episode began.
You don't know.
Try to think about how it
ended. You don't know. Right.
Because the narrative was never important.
The narrative was to
fill 30 minutes of time.
The only thing that was important where
the five sketches that fill that 30
minutes of time, 22 minutes
or 2022 yeah, exactly. So,
so it's like those five sketches don't
have to have that bullshit narrative.
Right,
right.
So right now you really just need four
or five friends that are doing the same
kind of funny shit. We're already
seeing the new sitcom right now.
It's already existing. Well on Instagram
it's just a not a good art form.
You know,
if you watch like the big bang or two and
a half man and those are grandfathered
in. Right. It's like that came
from a time when it was there.
But like they weren't,
they're not entertaining. They
certainly don't stand up.
Like that's also why Netflix kicked
in with a lot of their dramas.
Cause they can get away with things
on stranger things or on Ozark.
They can get away with shit you just
could never fucking do on regular
television. It's way more
wild. It's way more raw.
It's like you're watching a better movie.
They not only does,
cause it used to be that if you did film,
you didn't want to do television cause
television sucked. Right. Like television,
you do an air wolf or something like
that and doing something terrible shit.
It's obvious. You see it
coming a mile away. It's made
for morons. Yeah. Yeah. Or,
you know,
you did film and if you did film boy,
you got a chance to work with some of
the most amazing directors and do these
incredible pieces.
But Netflix came along and,
and really it was before Netflix
Soprano's laid the blueprint,
exact surprised wire the wire.
I didn't watch the wire,
but it did the same sort of thing,
right?
They created a new movie every week and
it all went together and it lasted a
hundred hours. Right? And
so you're like, oh my God.
Well regular movies is so shallow. I got
not even getting into the characters.
Right? Yeah, this guys, 10 years later,
you see him 10 years later and the
same movie, right? He's got a beard.
Fuck is this, this is terrible. And,
and why is it because movies
got so expensive to make.
You couldn't take risks on stories
that we didn't already know about.
Movies became 200 or a hundred million.
Now if I go to you and I'm like, okay,
give me 200 million to make a movie about,
it's this a mob guy and he's Kinda
got like some anxiety you like,
are you out of your fucking mind?
But if I say,
give me 200 million to make a
movie about marvel, it's like, oh,
that's an existing fan base.
Is it based on a book or a comic?
So right now the only movies we see are
either big budget that have a built in
audience or $3 million comedy.
Right.
That middle grounds right there. That
used to be awesome movies. TV. Yeah.
So now TV is the shit.
It's all these dope stores like
breaking bad should have been a movie,
but they turn that motherfucker into
a TV show. A betters. Yeah. And they
were restricted because it's
cable. There was an HBO, right.
And they had commercials and all
that stupid shit. Yeah. I mean,
what happened was with comics was the
internet came along and all the sudden
there was these,
this wealth of avenues where
comedians could show their work.
Whereas before you were
limited by the gatekeepers.
The gatekeepers were either sitcoms and
the sitcoms was what everybody wanted to
get. Cause you've got to sit
calm. Then you were all set.
You were Jerry Seinfeld
or you were Roseanne. Yup.
And then it became
something along the line.
Russell and you like both guys.
Russell Peters in particular. Yeah.
Became gigantic selling out arenas
from youtube. That's where it came.
I put little clips is shit came up.
And if you ever met Russell,
he's one of the most generous
guys in the world. Super Generous.
I know him comics who's rentees paid,
he's the best. He's just such a great guy.
But he's also a guy that recognizes that
you got to give some back. You gotta be,
and this just has his personality.
He's just so gregarious, outgoing guy.
All these podcasts that popped up,
people realize like, Hey, you know,
we're not in competition with each other
like Jay Leno and David Letterman work.
Cause everybody wanted
the tonight show spot.
Right now there's a thousand tonight
shows and if you have the tonight show and
I have the tonight show, I'm
like, hey, you should check
out Andrew's tonight show.
It's fucking great.
Like this is okay.
This is the tonight show your Carson.
But we figured out a way, Carson. Now,
do you know that? Right? That's
the difference. That's the shift.
That's why Netflix can't even compete.
Netflix has done, Dana had done, done,
what are you talking about?
You see Charlie Wilson's war,
no movie about Tom Hanks movie about
America getting an a evolved with the
Afghan conflict and Afghanistan
war doesn't really matter,
but the idea is yes,
they're fighting the Russians,
the Afghanis, right? Right.
So the Americans go, okay,
boom,
give them a $5,000 rocket launcher and
they're going to shoot down a $5 million
helicopter and eventually Russia
just won't be able to compete, right?
Netflix pays $100 million to Aaron
Sorkin or whoever to make a TV show,
right? Right. The distracts
you for two hours, right?
Youtube pay zero million dollars to Joe
Rogan and Jamie to make a podcast that
distracts you for two hours every day.
Netflix cannot compete,
but it's a different animal. You
got to realize, first of all,
they have way more people than just me.
They also are putting together something
that requires a lot of money to create.
Sure. You enjoy films. Yes, yes. Or
if you enjoy a show like Ozar, sure.
Stranger things along for narrative.
It takes a lot of money to make
those things are special effects.
There's camera people and
makeup people in here.
There's a lot of lock on art directors
and producers and actors and he'd say
giant fucking tense or with Pete,
but people aren't watching it.
You know what they're watching.
People are watching that.
They're watching friends. No,
no, no, no, no. In free, dude.
There's a reason they paid us terrible.
Does it matter if it's as Jamie
the most two most viewed shows on Netflix
right now? Netflix doesn't own, okay.
Netflix isn't even trying to make money
anymore. They're getting bought out.
It's Facebook, Amazon, but they want
it. That's the goal of the strategy.
Now the 10 billion in debt,
there's no way they can make money.
There's 10 billion and billion,
billion,
but they make hundreds of
millions of dollars a month.
Like how many people
do they have on board?
How many subscribers do they have
that are paying $9 as far as I know,
they don't share that information. They're
killing it in terms of subscribers,
but they're 10 billion in debt. They
just talk on another 2 billion. Right.
When I say Netflix has done, I'm speaking
when anytime I make declarations,
I'm speaking in the future. Right?
We prepare now for the future, right?
So it's like how will they hear it goes?
Netflix will keep friends through
next year and $100 million payment.
$100 million,
right?
For one year friends and then the
office to know what that is though.
That's like nostalgia style Jack.
Right?
So all viewing right now is
nostalgia even? Well, not all of you.
If you look at TV, right? What
the great, this, this, this
past year is in TV, right?
The OJ trial and FX.
What does that,
I remember how it was when the Oj
thing came out. Did Not do that great.
Killed it. Won all the awards,
everything. The Versace story,
which was another thing like what? That
out of the loop, I'm just 39 million.
139 million subscribers paying
$10 a month. Is that what it is?
How much the cross like that? Maybe even
more. Maybe 11 how much of the cost?
They just bumped it up to 12 I
think 12 bucks a month. Sure.
That ladies and gentlemen is
a fuck load of income. Sure.
So they got a lot coming in,
but they're spending a lot too because
they're trying to hundred 30 they're
trying to overtake all the others
and then they got Jeff Bezos,
you know captain money bags up there.
A scrooge McDuck right.
He's trying to do the same thing.
Facebook shoebox.
Just where I saw you on the pee
pee. Yeah. I was like, yeah, true.
But that's thing basles can lose money
on this shit because he's making tons of
money on paper towels and what,
whatever.
How much he is losing because he's
got a lot of fucking series at.
Ain't nobody watching them
that put it out there,
but he's doing something
that's even more weird. Okay.
Because there's no one
watching those shows. Yeah,
there's a ton of fucking shows on Amazon.
No fucking no one's watching.
I would like to see their numbers cause
I bet they have some shows they might,
they might have spent $1 million
to make and have like four viewers.
There's fucking no one watched these
shows. They were just going after awards.
They're thing was we're
going to make the artsy shit,
it's going to give us a grammy or
something like that and then we'll like
qualify our platform. It's a
smart approach. Like Youtube,
his approach was the exact
opposite, right. We're like,
we're just going to create this stuff
that we think people want to watch.
Well Youtube doesn't create much.
They did a little and they took
down the paywall. Like my thing I,
my guests with youtube is
there waiting for Netflix.
You know that scene in the
movie where like that somebody,
somebody's caught in like an enclosed
space and water starts coming in and the
water gets right up to like
his lips, you know, he's like,
he's trying to breathe a little bit more
and I think youtube is going to be the
one to pour the last drop of water.
Well I think it's such a different thing.
I think you're talking about totally
different things because Netflix has never
aimed to be a user created
content streaming site.
Right? The right they're not,
but at the end of the day
it's just distraction I think.
I think that's what we've got to start
looking at content as right is it,
it's just raw distraction and Netflix
occupies a space for distraction did
smaller than youtube,
so I can watch a two hour thing
on youtube at home on my TV.
I can watch a two minute thing on the
bus as I'm going to work on youtube,
you know, I can watch
a 15 minute, you know,
peace like Vlog or something like that.
I can watch all the whole spectrum.
Netflix. I'm really just watching
at home or like a foam on a trip.
You know what I mean? It's really, I'm not
watching a two minute thing on Netflix.
You know what I mean? It's, it is
the shit for now. Don't get me wrong.
It absolutely the shit for
now. Right. But if I was being,
if I'm putting my money on it, I
would say if I'm Facebook, I buy it.
And then imagine having
your Facebook feed,
you just watched a show and then you
get to share it immediately on your
Facebook followers.
Facebook,
I'd be super careful about buying anything
cause I think the government's been
thinking about breaking them up for a
while and Elizabeth Warren is already
talking about that.
That's one of the parts of her platform
and running for president is breaking up
apple, breaking up Facebook,
breaking up Twitter.
She wants to break up all these
things she thinks are monopolies.
What's your feeling on that?
Get the fuck Outta here with that shit
is goofy is goofy's fuck. What's up?
Disney takeover of 21st century
Fox takes place, I think next week.
The 20th to Bega. They're going to put
out their own streaming, everything.
They've just,
they've bought like everything except
for Fox News and Fox sports took over all
of their production movie facilities.
It's like 5,000 people might be losing
their job because all that contents
coming off a Netflix,
all those marvel shows,
all that shit is going to come over to
them. So now they're going to have a nice,
they've been canceling all
these marvel shows on Netflix.
I keep investing in something
that you're going to take off,
like I'm going to build up a brand and
then you're going to remove it, right?
They've got, so they got all the
kids movies. You're a bear a dad,
you know what I mean? Dude, I go to
Disneyland twice a year at least.
Which you're gonna not have
a streaming Disney program.
Apple's also starting their streaming
service soon tomorrow or some shit on
those win. But there's a bunch, I'm,
tons of rumors are comfortable today.
You know what it's like, you know, the
perestroika, like what happened in Russia,
like where the, uh, overnight,
you know, it fell and they
sold off the state assets.
Like a few people and everybody
came. Billionaires, right.
That's what's happening right
now in entertainment, dude.
People don't realize it,
but like it's fucking done.
Like the days of the days of like
fame being about distance are done.
Distance, distance. Like I'm Johnny Depp.
I'm going to go away to my like little
home somewhere in the Alps and you will
see me twice a year. You're
not, I'm weird. Or Marlon
Brando. I'm, I'm out here.
I'm weird. I'm different. You
know. It's like now it's proximity.
There's a reason why no value
in being weird anymore. Well,
Marlon Brando. Tyler Perry
has an island, bro. Really?
That's interesting. Have you been
invited? No. No. That's fucked up.
I don't want to go. I ain't going to
anybody's fucking island. That's my rule.
Bronson. Somebody wants to
ask what's in the Virgin Dude?
Richard Bronson or whatever his name is.
Johnson Branson.
Yank on his fucking island. I don't want
to hang out with a dude with Branson.
Why? Why? When I could jet ski with Joey.
T is, listen, I ain't, I don't know.
Hanging out with any dude who has
an island. Get the fuck Outta here.
Mccone or island because they always want
you to go to the island. Like, bitch,
I ain't going to, your island is going
to the diner. No. Who, who's that?
Eddie Murphy. Eddie Murphy has an
island. Yep. What would you get up?
You go to Eddie's. I'm might go daddy's.
He got it. Got It. I like Getty.
I met Eddie and I was good friends
with his brother and good guy.
Petrolia was the best. Charlie was the
greatest guy of all time. Yeah. Uh,
I met Eddie when,
when I met Eddie Murphy,
I met Eddie Murphy in Maui and he'd go
it first words out of his mouth. He goes,
you are funny, motherfucker. I was
like, God damn. Yes. This is recently,
no years ago. Maybe more
than 10 years ago. Yeah.
That's like 2007 something like
that. It'd be unreal. Crazy funny.
In Hawaii with my family,
I'll say thank you. Like,
what do you say when Eddie Murphy says
you're a funny motherfucker? I'm like,
Holy Shit. Wow. It felt great. You know,
she looked at your wife and be like see
chuckle every once in a while. Yeah.
Honestly, at home, I'm not that funny.
My wife cracks most of the jokes. Really?
Yeah. I don't have to be funny
like a, I don't need it. You know,
it's one of the reasons why I like to
hang around with Joey Diaz cause he's
always funny and he's always the
funny guy. You know? I like it.
It's uh, you know, I like being
around funny people, man. I'm not,
the thing about comics, especially the
needy annoying ones and the early days,
like early days of your career, they
have to be the center of attention. Yeah.
That shit is really annoying.
And one of the things that you learned
for sure about hosting a podcast is you
don't really want to be
the center of attention.
You just want to
facilitate a conversation.
You just want to make the best creation.
What's the best creation?
The best creation is let this guy rant.
You gotta let them rent.
Get out of the way.
If the best creation as rent with them,
you jump in together and you'd go
back and forth like a game of tennis,
then you do it that way,
but you have to be able to feel the vibe
and then some people are not going to
like it that way. They're
going to want it. Well,
why don't you let your guests talk?
Like people love to say shit like that.
Like you wonder why you interrupted his
rants. I love to say things like that.
See like you're trying to make a
creation. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There's a,
comics are not great listeners.
Some of them are as well.
The ones that are are great at this.
Yeah. Right. And uh, the ones that are,
it's tough for them to do this and
people know, man, they, it's, it's
how, how comfortable is it when it
gets in through their ears? Yeah.
Like is it getting an easy or
is it like, oh, this guy's on.
No, yeah, yeah. I'll
bring on a guest here.
The guests say something and I just
cringe because I anticipate the comments.
I'm just like, dude, you're about to
get crushed by the weight of the world.
Will you?
Well, you quiet somebody.
No, I mean if I have to, uh,
try not to,
if I have to correct them,
like if they're saying something
that I know to be inaccurate,
if it's in my wheelhouse,
like sometimes people say something
and I'll just say that's not,
that's not true. Here's why
that's not true. You know,
I've had people say some goofy shit and
it just happens to be something I know a
lot about and then I have to stop it.
Yeah, okay. That makes, that makes sense.
But for the most part, I, I want
people to just be themselves.
I got to figure out how
to get you to be yourself.
That's what a lot of this is
comfortable make you realize that.
I just want you to do great.
I want everybody to do great.
Are you ever intimidated by a
guest? By their intellect? Yeah.
Like Elon Musk was intimidating talking
to him cause you realize what a champ
you are still that way. Oh
yeah. I'm a fucking dummy man.
But like talking to this guy, I'm like,
I'm a fucking chimp. Here's a question.
He's just kind of like a champ one
should I got to go to Mars?
Huh. Cool wants smokes weed.
Okay.
He's got a big a cut of that
mother making electric cars, you
know, sending rockets into the space.
He's drilling holes under the ground.
You had to dumb them down
with Megan solar cities.
We didn't even, didn't even work,
but, so here's my take on it. Right.
I'm watching Musk.
Right.
And he basically is opening up to
you about how he's not happy. Yeah,
right.
There's this moment where he's like,
I think he said something to stand
of you one want to be me. Yeah.
He's just as his exact words.
He wouldn't want to be mean.
You wouldn't want to be me.
So that means he doesn't want to be him.
I think on some level he doesn't
want to be him. Right. And
he's so with these guys that we admire
because they're so brilliant and they
have all these brilliant ideas and we're,
we're putting this matrix of we're all
in this success matrix. On some level,
right? Where it's like get things done
good. Don't they can get things on bad.
Right?
I wonder if
if he's chimp ish in that he's potentially
wasting his life being upset or
miserable when he could be focusing
on things that would give them joy.
Is that being,
is that being a fucking chimp is being
so smart that you don't even try to just
be happy and focus on your happiness?
I don't
necessarily think he's unhappy,
but I do think that he puts himself into
situations where the amount of stress
that he absorbs is almost unfathomable.
Like when he was trying to get the Tesla
model three production re scheduled
ramped up and he was sleeping on the
floor of the factory and working literally
working like 1920 hours a day.
That that's untenable.
You can only do that for
short periods of time. Right.
But I think that what I was saying
about Kanye West applies to him tenfold.
Okay.
He's,
he's got a power output that's
extraordinarily different
than the average person.
And that's one of the things he was
talking about when he was young. I mean,
you could probably put
him on some sort of, uh,
W W I don't know what the
super genius spectrum is,
right? Like what is, you know,
what's, what's Albert Einstein, right?
What's, what's this guy? What's that guy?
He's in there somewhere and it's crazy
realm of the way your brain works.
Like, I think the brains are
like all other body parts.
Some people born with little tiny dicks
and some people got giant hogs and
that's just a fact.
And I think that dude has
a giant hot of a brain
and it just works better.
It just,
it just is operating on a level that
you and I can't, we can't comprehend.
But I never invented a
God damn thing in my life.
But I'm driving around and
Elon Musk's car, you know,
that mother fucker made a car and that's
like some shitty does on the side.
You know, his car thing is like,
after he invented paypal and he's,
by the way,
while he's doing the car,
he shoot rockets into space and
drilling holes into the ground.
He's trying to move traffic on the ground.
It's trying to fuck it.
He's making solar cities like he's,
he's hooking up Australia with these
massive solar panel power battery plants
and fucking fix their energy
needs. He's, he's on another level.
No doubt. On another level it's a
different thing, but so is he happy gel?
I don't know. And that's a nice guy
that was hanging around with him.
He seems happy. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, yeah,
it does. There was what is happy, right?
Is He happy in bursts when,
well,
I guarantee you when I saw him and he was
shooting his fucking flame thrower and
my, my four, Yay. He was happy. You're
four. Yay. Yeah. Right out here, man.
Yeah.
He had a fucking flame thrower.
He was tapping that bitch
when he walked into the door.
He's unboxing it in the middle of
this hallway out here got flames.
There's a picture of him standing in
front of the Freak Party sign blown flames
out freely.
I fucking guy's a maniac.
Look at the smile on his face.
He can't tell me he's not happy, Bro.
You know what? Look at that smile.
He's happy as fuck. It's cause he's a
kid, man. Yeah. We're just a lot of ways.
There's this,
there's this fucking guy,
I forget his name is doctor a wrap or a
pie or something like that. He's like,
his French consulting is like some fucking
genius and he's like decoded cultures,
right?
And uh,
every culture he's Dakota and he,
people hire him to consult. Right?
And like America's code is a,
it's a,
the verb is to do and the time is now.
Right.
And we're just kids at the end of
the day. Right. It's like everything.
We love big tits in America,
right?
Most popular product is big tits and like
France, most popular project surgeries,
getting tits reduced,
right.
Everything about them is
like precision and like
the food on the plate,
they're most popular plastics.
That's what I was talking to my
buddy and that's what he said.
And maybe it's changed to like
lips or something more common now,
but maybe the one you have to
go under episode or dark one.
Don't fuck with your lips ladies.
I like it when they get a little lips.
If they have not,
if you have a fucking beak,
but then do you want to have
a little something? You see
the, the thing in there,
it's like, like let's, you
know, they're extra needy.
There's like something going on. They
wanted the, they wanted their lips to be,
you know,
there's like a symmetrical proportion
that your face is supposed to fall into
this Fibonacci sequence of
numbers and if you get a nose job,
I look at you and I go, Whoa, what's
wrong with it is like something is wrong.
It registers wrong in my head because
your face, so like Ari, perfect example.
It's already got a nose job. You're like,
what the fuck is happening here? Yes.
What's wrong with your face?
But you've already had like a small
Irish person's nose. He'd be like,
what is happening here? This doesn't
even make any sense. Not for his face,
his face. It's that there's a sequence,
like your lips match your face. They,
they match how far your eyes
are a part where your nose is.
We see a girl and she's a little tiny
little skinny thing with little fingers
and all of a sudden she's got this yes,
these big weird lips don't we
like things that like stand out.
Like we like skinny with big
tits. We do drawn to it. Right.
Things are abnormally do most big slot.
It's a trick.
The big tip one is a trick because it,
it represents like sexual viability.
It represents your ability to breastfeed
a child which is attractive to your
genes. Doesn't make any sense. Yeah.
I said you would know that there's a bag
of water underneath her skin that she
had a tube down her throat taped
to her face. She's half dead.
They're cutting our open with a sharp
knife and scuffing this bag of water under
the meat of her breast tissue or they're
cutting her nipple often opening up
like a fucking man hole cover and
pumping that fucker in there. It's crazy.
Like we know that that's what
happened and we still think it's hot.
The all those things are nuts.
Chilean bro. Yeah. Yeah. In
here, we can't help it, but
like it bothers me when it's a, but
when it's a fake, but it bothers me.
Like if there was a way that a girl could
lift weights at the gym and make her
tits bigger and she went and got
fake tits, wouldn't like him as much.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. Knowing you can earn it. Yeah.
You could earn it. I might. Yeah. It's
lazy. Lazy. Yeah. Yeah. But thing is,
it throws you off if it doesn't match
the legs. Like if a girl's got a big,
but it's got some legs, like damn bitch
is dead lift. You know, like that's hot.
Yeah. It's like, I've never said that in
my head, but I know what you're talking.
You never said this. Bitches deadlift
putting up. I see a girl with big,
big hamstrings. Bitch could squat.
Death isn't, I say that all the time.
Just don't work out enough.
I guess.
I was like girls with legs that looked
like ticking carry shit. Yeah, it's hot.
Yeah.
Do you like the girl?
I'm heavy of the girls carrying me around.
She's going to get tired,
but it, but I like girls that are
athletic but of power. You know,
I like it. It's hot. So if a girl's
got a big ass cause she's squatting,
that's hot. The girls get a big ass
cause she went through surgery. I'm like,
bitch, you're going to get cancer
as cancer now. Do you know that
from implants? Yes. They're starting
to see cases of bud cans. Whoa, Jack.
That's what I'm talking
about son, Bro. That's power.
That's too strong for me. Oh,
don't be scared. I'm afraid of that.
That girl hurt you. Yeah, that is,
that's like trying to
fuck up crossfitters fist.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the power she must have in that Bro.
Look at that leg dude. And
attaches a hawk. Outstanding.
I mean the butt cheeks or anything.
It's the thigh meat. It's too much.
He's a athlete. I like it.
Yeah. I don't know like that.
If that girl's in a miniskirt,
but if she's not flexing
Cipro looks hot as fuck you.
So you were into a very strong, yeah,
I like good jeans, this kind of thing.
Other ones, Jamie. I mean this
girl has stacked that girl stacked.
The only problem with those gals is that
there is a reality to certain levels of
musculature that most likely they're
only achieved by injecting male hormones.
So the cliques kind of get big or
whatever. Have you never seen that?
Are you allowed to like fuck around?
What's your relationship with your wife?
Definitely not. No. No. No. Okay. Okay.
How long have you been married? 10 years.
10 years, okay. And then how do you, yeah.
How do you navigate that? No, Jay yet.
Can you please explain to me what need you
do this? Wait, Jack will help. Exactly.
How does it work? Yeah. This,
this level of athleticism.
I was saying like there's like a certain
line that there are, they are crossing,
most likely is because of male hormones.
Yeah. I can't get into it. There's,
there's some level of that. Did
they grow some hair? Jujitsu girls,
there's a lot of Jujitsu
girls that are competitive.
Jiu Jitsu girls that started
doing a little bit of steroids.
They started taking a
little bit of testosterone.
Like a friend of mine's wife was
doing it and I was like, yikes. Yeah.
She's really getting into a Jujitsu.
She's competing and she's starting
to take a little bit of testosterone.
I was like, Oh, you know what happens?
They get horny where he only
like a dude. Really? Yeah,
but they've got this big dangling clay
on or know it only gets big when they go
whole hog.
Like when they go bodybuilder.
How Nagel bodybuilder big.
No, never way back in the day.
They never fucked a girl was a
bodybuilder. Never once ever just fuck.
The girl was like, like very
fit and strong, but she had
a normal vagina. Normal.
Totally normal. She has a six pack
though. It's kind of weird. Okay. Yeah.
It's a little soft feminine.
But this clip thing fascinates me,
so declared it just is there like, is
that, you can't put a picture of that up.
Can we look at that? Can you pull it
up when it doesn't? You know what?
It is a little Dick. It's like a
little deck. That's what I'm wondering.
Does it have like the head
and like the race? Oh yeah.
Fuck you ever see here, Bro.
You saying you've never looked at
in large clits you never done that.
It's exactly what I'm saying. If
you've never done it, Google search.
I looked fake pussies.
I looked up like training pussies,
but I didn't look up and those are good.
What do you mean the training buzzy?
What do you mean they're not good? Like
date? Sound good. It's not real. Yeah,
I know it's not real, but you want
to be able to tell. Can you tell? No,
but I feel like there's
a dick on inside and nut.
That one down there.
Yeah.
That's what happens. It's not real. It
is real. It is real way. No, no, no,
it is no way. How about that one in the
lower right hand, upper right hand corner.
The dark one. Jamie below that. That
one. Pow. How'd you like me now?
That's a dick. She has balls. Yeah. No,
no. That's pussy lips, bro. That's not,
that's not a girl. That's
Paul's lips. Doug Pussy Lips.
Now that one down there.
What about the giant one below that
Jamie did the ones that middle.
What's happening there? No, Bro,
that just looks like a witch finger
is gnarly.
That's Photoshop has to be from my dude,
dude. This is awesome. Free Porn. Mm.
Yeah. Oh Dude. Well,
when girls take a lot of testosterone,
they do develop enlarge clits.
There was a a a show
on HBO back in the day,
I think it was called private dicks,
but it was like that girl's Jack.
You're into that though? No,
that's a little much. Yeah.
Dillashaw yeah, that's hilarious. She's
pretty looking now. She wasn't flexing,
told to eat a couple of sandwiches. Oh.
Anyway, let's get out of there. That's,
that's enough. We're going to
start vomiting mood. But anyway,
there was a show on HBO called Private
Dicks and one of the people on it,
I think that was from that show,
but anyway,
there was this lady who was talking about,
she became a,
a trans man and by through taking
massive amounts of testosterone,
her clit grew. She said to
the size of a thumb. Yeah,
because they're taking,
I don't even understand what's going on.
High levels of testosterone to sort of
achieve that. They get hair on their face.
They're boys DPA. Yeah. You know,
they get broader and thicker and they
keep a lot of that too. I, I don't get it.
I don't understand. So your clit is just,
your is just a cock essentially, right?
Well, not really. It just resembles
one. I mean if you looked at that,
if my dick look, I thought I'd go right
to the doctor. I'm like, which one?
We were looking at the cook
and one which is finger joints.
It seems like a joint.
It seems like a club with no skin or
get dick with no skin. It has been.
Yes.
That made me feel
uncomfortable to look at.
It should match and pulling
a girl's panties and shit.
That thing fucking happen to
a friend of mine's boyfriend,
a friend of mine who I used to
work with on a television show her,
she was the story about her ex boyfriend
met this girl and they're fooling
around and they get back to her
butt and she was pretty feminine,
but she had a click,
like a pinky is the way he described it
and then he pulled her pants down and
then fucking panicked and then said,
oh my God,
I have to pick my friend up at the
airport. Fuck, I can't believe this.
And he just, that was his excuse
is I got to pick one panty man.
The dude panicked. He went into a
full blown panic and just ran out.
He couldn't deal with her clit.
I mean it gets to a certain
size where that's like at, look,
it's wrapped around her leg
and tied in a bow. You're like,
oh you to like kind of like
push it to the side to insert.
You gotta hold it like a handle
all your banners and choice.
Fuck it. It's like the,
the reins on a horse,
like you're hanging onto it.
Where you're bang on. Oh,
it's like just the random shape of the
human body and how we've decided that
this is what's appealing. Right.
Hourglass figure. The ask comes out,
the tits are here. It makes it look
like she's like sexually viable.
She'll be good at like the big ass and
all that fat around that area means she's
got a plenty, plenty of nutrients
for the child. Got Wide Hips.
It means a baby's gonna come out easy.
All those things are like
directly connected to fertility.
So we're not objectifying
them at all. Well, we are,
but it's nature that's caught.
Like there's a reason why the standard
that men are after when it comes to women
is directly connected to them.
It actually makes some kids,
so me thinking, you know,
you have great, you know,
hips are tits or something like that
is efficient. Yeah. It's not sexist.
It's not hateful.
It's not in any way objectifying.
Or maybe we're supposed to
objectify to create people. Hmm.
I think there's that too.
But then there's also like if
a girl's really good shape,
one of the things that you
admire is that that girl's got,
she's got disciplined and power,
like go girls hitting the gym all the
time and working on all a girl gets things
done.
Like if you see a girl and she's lazy
and her body is just like soft doughy,
she's like skinny fat, like, like,
oh, you're going to complain a lot.
You're going to meet a lot of
naps. Yay. You know what I mean?
You know it up after this kid
getting after it. Yeah. You know,
I have to get things done now. You're
going to want to be, you want to be sad,
you're going to want to complain. You're
going to want to stay home and stop.
But is that biological or is that
a smart, do you think it is? Yeah.
There's something biological to it.
Your body rejects that because
you know that this girl,
like if the shit hits the fan
and a fucking apocalypse comes,
you gotta take your children
and go to the mountains. Right.
This girl is going to be tired all
the time. I'm just going to complain.
It's going to weigh you down.
It's not going to carry your own weight.
I'll like a gal who can
carry your own weight. Right,
and you can't do that if
you're carrying a big old clit
hurry up, dragging your clit all over
the rocks. We got leaves stuck to it.
Shit.
Dog's Dick Dog.
No, no. Imagine if women had,
and men had pussies and we were just
really into big dicks to just as possible.
Absolutely called gay guys,
but no,
the arbitrary shape it like strange,
strange.
You're a trashy.
This isn't the male.
Seahorses have a pussy while the male
seahorse excepts eggs from the female.
This actually video of
it sounds pretty great.
That's pretty fucking
gay brown eggs. Yeah. He,
she pours her eggs into a sack
in his body. It's very strange.
It looks like they're kissing while
they do it. It's really weird, right?
I'm okay with, Oh, you've got a video
of it. Oh yeah. Here it is. Shit.
In perspective, when you look at the
weird fucking animal, a sea horses anyway,
like what a strange little creature.
It's so weird.
I think that's why we like
nature stuff because it like,
it puts in perspective how fucked up
humans are. Look at that dude. That's,
that's her. Him. Is that him giving
birth do, that's how I come with cow.
Look at that kicks back and
shotgun dude come the opposite way.
I've go forward and I don't get back out.
I feel like if you back on,
it's like pulling back on a punch.
Yeah.
But you gotta match one of
those ones that stuck in there.
One of them little baby seahorses is
like, ah, I'm in it forever. Shit.
Cause he's, the last of them is like
the last is like one or two at a time.
So you're like one guy. Oh
boy. That's the last draw.
He's just, he keeps popping, but
there's nothing coming out. Okay.
Those are babies are, those are sperm
babies. So we didn't see them like, uh,
have sex with each other. Maybe
hatches inside of his body. Yeah.
That's crazy dude. Thank God I got
to do that. I imagine all that.
What a drag. Did your, did your
wife do natural now? See? Oh No, no,
no, no, no, no. How'd she get it
out? Oh, I mean natural and that,
but like, yeah, a c section, ga epidural
man. The csection thing, they have to,
I mean with some women it's
imperative they have to do it.
Like maybe they have small hips, right?
You date one of those, like a little girl,
take one of them bent big giant dudes
Grill Fox, you know what I mean?
And then he got a giant baby
side you and a little tiny pussy
loving.
I am fascinated by it when
like if you ever seen that guy,
the guy from game of Thrones,
the guy on the mountain,
the mountain was this little tiny. She's
standing up, she weighs three pounds.
Let's see, she looks like a chick.
She's smaller in comparison to him.
Then my eight year old is in comparison
to mill. Yup. Look at that. Oh,
he is smoking that dude.
Oh,
how is that humanly
possible that that works?
She's this beautiful little tiny creature
and he's one of the biggest human
beings on the planet. He's packing. I
don't think he's packing. Are you talking?
I think he's got a big piece.
He's got a dick.
Like everything else you see on him.
If he didn't have a dick like that,
you'd be stunned by the size of his hands,
his shoulders.
He probably has a small seal in his pants.
He's going to tee shirts. A strong
mother fuckers be like besides Dick?
Yeah,
big giant fucking ant
eater or on elephant trunk.
That's, that's, oh wow.
I don't know if he got the peace man big.
If you had a piece like that.
He's a savage. She's from fucking
Iceland. That's what they do.
There are different humans out
there, man. Those are vikings.
There's a reason why he's that big.
No bullshit. That is Viking DNA.
It's just the best.
Years ago,
guys like him would be on a boat where
they fucking dragon on the front of the
boat and they'd have a sword and they
couldn't wait to jump off that fucking
boat and start hacking people to bits.
That's why that guy exists.
That's why he's so big and you just took
the best genetics from wherever you've
stopped. It's why Iceland vice did
a whole piece on Iceland. Okay.
But all of the strong men, competition
winners, it live in Iceland.
They're all vikings. Mad.
It's Viking DNA. Really?
100% okay. But isn't Viking
DNA. Okay? We went to Italy,
we raped some chicks in Italy. We bring
them back. They bring back the best women,
but they're the ones who survive
all these battles. This is tested
at other duties to survive.
We're all big. Yeah, that's
true. These guys are so big, man.
If you got to read this article, had
vice did on these strong men in Iceland.
Okay. It's crazy bro. Yeah, yeah. As
a whole country filled with gorilla
gorillas that are just smashing pussy
and lifting weights and throwing fucking
beer barrels over the top of train
link fences there. It's huge.
There's a apparently that there's an APP
in Iceland to make sure you don't fuck
your family member that ass bro.
Cause there's only,
there's only like 300,000 people right on
the island. So everybody, not everybody,
a lot of people are very related
so you can like type your name in.
Oh say oh your grandson,
all your organs in our
second cousins family.
Not Fuck.
Oh,
with a drum by the bed.
I got to do beat the drum.
Boom, boom. The gimme a pace to go to
jam. That's a crazy, crazy race of
humans, man. You ever go there? No. No.
I'd like to go. I'd like to go there
just to see the northern lights.
It's one of the things that
I've been thinking that I need.
Have you been where you saw them? I didn't
sign up there. What is it? Oh you did?
Yeah. Normally in Alaska it's harder in
the city when you're just say, but uh,
yeah, they love stand
up there. I think like,
I think they're they're
president or something. It
was like a huge Stan hope fan.
They liked good stand up to make sure
I'm not misquoting but like a pair.
I think he was a like a
massive, a duck. Stan Hope Fan.
They were good man. They like no English.
They're like apparently the KFC there,
KFC one KFC, it's popular as fuck. Well,
the rules for food are super like high,
so it's like the best chicken
tenders you ever had. Oh,
because they don't let process bullshit.
None of that. Right, but it's still KFC,
so you could do that when
you have a country that has
as many people as Boulder,
Colorado.
That's the thing people don't get,
like when you got to
feed 300 million people,
it's like we're going to jam out some
shit, Bro. Like we're going to use corn,
300 million people. It's a lot of people.
It's like when a mom has nine kids,
it's like it's going to
be some grits. Yeah, yeah.
Mcdonald's is going to work, but yeah,
Iceland was a shit in the northern lights.
You look at northern
lights and you're like, oh,
I completely get why people
believed in God. Oh yeah.
Like you can't not. Does
that make sense? Sure.
You look in the sky and
it's painting itself.
You're going to believe what
did they think it was back then?
Had to be the gods dancing.
I wonder what they thought.
I'm wondering what ex explanation
they had for the northern lights.
How do you not like years ago.
I don't know man.
Sometimes the more I like look at,
I was raised without any religion,
but like the more I look at it now, I
think it's just people trying to explain.
It was like, it was like people just
look at that. It's not a real color.
Minnesota. Yeah. Yeah. You can see
it. Wow. But go to another one for me.
I didn't experience right.
Guess Novitsky it's more just that name.
Dirk Nowitzki are probably thinking,
oh no,
I've heard that name to
Travis Novitsky. Is He, um,
what's that got to do? Is he just
a famous photographer? Perhaps
try to follow yeah. Photography
by Travis Novitsky. Yeah,
I think that's what it is. I
think. I think I've seen his, yeah,
I think he does a lot of nature
shit. Yup. How could you not dude?
Like how can you, how do you blame anybody
for, for believing in something bigger?
Oh, just a lightning storm, man. A
hurricane. Like we live in big cities.
This shit is not real.
You live in The Bahamas and you see
the power of a fucking hurricane.
It puts things in perspective.
You know how important we think we are.
That goes away when you know at
the blink of an eye, your house,
everything you work for is gone
because of wind, wind and water.
Holy Shit. Shit. Right there. Look at that
picture. That's where it's crazy. Wow.
Says Northern.
The lights now appear in central Europe
and is because of climate change.
Well isn't he supposed to get hotter?
I don't know what that means.
Like why is it saying well go to
that article. Why is it saying that
northern light now up here.
What? What does that go?
Scroll down. Scroll down. No,
it says Europe,
much of the US Central Europe and much
of the U S I didn't know that much of the
u s says northern lights. You can
see him in Ohio. Sometimes Alaska.
You can see the norm. You've
seen it. I have not. But um,
I mean the other picture
you share on an Minnesota,
you fucking Ohio people do
an ass in the parking lot.
Seeing the lights in the sky.
Yeah.
There's that fucking big storm is
hitting central us today. Right? Fuck.
Then like Denver where they call it a
bomb. A bomb cyclone has it's clickbait.
Margaret Marketing. Good
marketing. Is it a bomb?
Like why are they calling it a bomb?
Because you're going to read
the article of is a bomb, right?
Bombs are scary to marketing's fucking
everything. I thought this shit like,
like when we were just talking about
the uncircumcised, like, like that.
Even that term is so dumb,
right? It's a normal dick.
Yeah. Yeah. That's what it is.
It's a dick. Why don't we, why
would we even use that? Yeah.
Right. Well, what's crazy is
it, it's more common to be cut.
You're D it's more common than a dick
is sliced off when you're a baby.
They take the cap off than it is, and
then when it's not, we're like, what's,
why didn't your parents cut your cock
when you were born? What about that?
Why do you have the blanket over the top
of the head? I cut that off. Expose that.
Dry that head out. Yeah. Weird.
Yeah. It's just sitting there.
You get people to believe anything.
It's like you got to grow it into them.
You know, there's this, uh,
I feel like I tell the story every
single time talking on podcast,
but like there's this great thing about
how Nescafe broke into the Japanese
market. Have you heard about this? And
it's like they went to this consultant,
they're asking them how do we get in?
And then he's like, you can't get in.
And they're like, what do you mean?
You're saying it's going to be 15 years?
And I will be talking
about, and he goes, well,
they don't know what the fuck
coffee is over there. Okay,
you're trying to be tea or not tea.
So what you're gonna do is you're going
to make a cartoon and you're going to
spend some few million on that and then
you're gonna make a candy based on a
cartoon. And then that candy is
going to be flavored as coffee.
And when these kids grow up,
they're going to have this memory of
coffee and the flavor of the smell of
coffee.
And I think last week they just opened
the biggest Starbucks in the world and
Tokyo and these people
devour coffee like no other.
And the idea is like the takeaway for me,
the reason why I tell
the story all the time,
it's like change comes from underneath,
you know what I mean?
Is this how they approached it? They
actually did it that way. That's, that's,
that's the same guy,
the
consultant [inaudible] I think his
name is and he's a book or something.
I'll call the culture code.
My buddy is doing like a series
with him trying to break it down,
but the idea is like if you want to change
any same reason why I did my shit on
youtube, it's like if you want to change
any industry or something like that,
it's never going to come within
the traditional structure.
You know what I mean?
It's like I would never be able to do
the type of jokes I was doing on, on.
Maybe you are in the bigs can but me.
They'd be like, I don't that jokes about,
you know, trans people,
you can do that, et cetera.
So it's like if I want to make it okay,
I got to do it outside.
You don't have to go a little bit outside
of the industry and make it okay and
way they were thinking was,
hey,
let's get underneath and just
fucking grow these ideas in.
That's why we fight wars over
ideas all the time. Right.
It's like people understand Oh shit,
and people start believing in socialism
or whatever the new thing they want us
to be afraid of. Now they believe
in it and it sounds good enough.
They'll want it. So we got to nip
this in the bud and Vietnam, you know,
there's a little bit of that.
I mean,
Vietnam was super complicated
depending on who you ask.
Most likely it was about heroin, a lot of
the whole war. You think lot of it. Yeah.
A lot of it was about the heroin trade.
Billions,
billions and billions and billions of
dollars controlling the heroin trade.
Really? Yeah. More so then then
the spread of this ideology,
standards about the heroin trade.
My understanding was w yeah,
I understood that a little
heroin ramped up radically,
but there's all sorts of
positive aspects to, uh,
most of the ideas that
they push. Right, right.
There's positive aspects of
trying to stop terrorism.
There's positive aspects of trying to
stop radical fundamentalists for taking
over parts of the world and radicalizing
segments of the population and making
these terrorist cells and attacking
cities and doing a lot of things that we
know really do happen that that's true,
but what's also true,
it's a hotbed for heroin,
so it's a win win.
There's a Geraldo Rivera segment on Fox
News where Geraldo Rivera was talking to
soldiers who were guarding poppy fields
and they were explaining that the US
soldiers had to guard the fucking heroin
because this is how they got these
Afghany farmers to cooperate against
the radical fundamentalist that were
running these religious sex.
Watch this shit,
put the headphones on
fighting the opium trade.
Marsha, this town in the middle of Helmand
province, a province was the easy part.
The hard part now is governing this
province. A province as you suggest,
that has become addicted to opium in many,
many ways.
That is the principle of crop that is
being grown here. The Taliban land,
the farmers, the money, they
are indebted to the Taliban.
They have to grow the opium now the
marines in their success or in a sense of
victim of their success. Because
now the population is a, you know,
they have these OPM fields
and we are tolerating it.
We are tolerating the cultivation of the
OPM because we know that if we were to
destroy it now,
the population were turned against the
marines and it would be a real crazy
risks. Let me introduce Lieutenant Colonel
Brian Christmas here at the command,
Yardi for Syrup, the third
battalion, sixth marines. Uh,
really a wonderful group of marines here.
Cause this a kid,
I knew him that youtube,
who's going to be a problem this
now stop now because so,
but they're getting heavy with heavy
handed against copyright. So isolation,
this is in spring cause this is this,
is this the gray area we were talking to?
This was early in the war.
I mean this is like what was that from?
I want to say that was probably
from 2005. Yeah, dude, this is,
yeah, this is the gray, right?
This is, hey, this is how
a country makes its money.
There's,
it's not just that someone's profiting,
there's fucking,
they millions for their GDP.
Some one is profiting.
I do not know where the money's all going,
but there are Boone's of dollars
involved in heroin. Right?
Billions people are buying
it all over the world.
90 something percent of it comes
from Afghanistan. Do the math,
just do the math.
We're still there.
And Sturgill Simpson wrote a bit about
it or wrote a song about it and they
played that song on Saturday night live.
And I don't even think they knew what
the fuck the song was about. Right.
I mean he's up there playing a song about
the government being involved in the
heroin trade. I mean it's,
there's, there's something to it.
There's some in and you say, oh,
it's conspiracy theory. Stop,
stop.
There really is billions of dollars
in heroin being grown in Afghanistan.
The production of heroin really
did ramp up considerably.
The US invasion.
Um,
is it possible that this is their
commerce and country singer goes on,
SNL exposes Afghan heroin trade and
no one even noticed. That's my boy.
But he's in terms of Thompson,
but that this is their commerce and the
same way like some communities fish this
community plants,
poppies and they perhaps,
what are they doing with all that money?
That's the question.
I'm more goats or they get it. Whether
done Afghany go to diligent. I mean
I don't know what they're doing.
I don't know.
I just can't imagine someone is not
getting a cut of this and I can't imagine
that there's no,
might as well just know
mainstream investigative work
that's being done to sort
of expose this. I don't know.
I mean I might be wrong.
Maybe these farmers are
not making all the money.
Maybe the money's all going to drug
dealers and we, we let that happen.
That'd be fucked up. It'd be cool if it'd
be cool if they got it, but like, look,
the world is fucked Bro. Like this
shit ain't peaches and cream men.
It's like every time I see one of these
stupid Senate hearings where they're
like, did you do some bad things
in South America? Like yeah, yeah.
That shit happens when
Trudeau was involved in that
thing in like a, what is it,
La, Libya. You know like when they
were bribing. You heard about this,
Trudeau from Canada,
they're happy.
There's this big scandal up there in
Canada because he was involved with this
company,
which is a [inaudible] company that was,
that paid like $36 million to bribe the
light Libyan government for like some
contracts and it's like, well, yeah,
that's how shit gets done over there.
You bribe the government for contracts
and these people in the Canadian
government, like, how could
he, this is against his
policies. It's like, no, no, no.
Welcome to the real world that you're
operating in the 1% of the world which has
these rules.
We just made the fuck up of fairness
and equality and equity and all this
bullshit. It's like the real world
is, hey, I'd like to do this.
Can I give you some money and we
make it happen. The real world is,
Hello Geraldo Rivera walking into
heroin fields, talking to a general,
that's the real fucking world.
There's a lot of that. Yeah,
I mean it would be nice if everywhere
was like America, but I don't know if it,
that's what's really fucked up.
Right? Like with this Fairphone shit.
I don't know if that gets done.
I don't know.
I don't know if you get an iPhone unless
it's getting made by someone who's
making $5 a week. I don't know
if you do. And if you do get it,
how much does it cost? Tons. What is
it like $3,000 how much does it cost?
How much does an iPhone? Who's going to
pay it? Like you, you already struggling.
You already got two kids, right?
I mean like you bills to pay,
like you're going to spend $3,000
when you're already struggling.
We're operating from a place
where we have some excess.
People are trying to make it every
day here. Yeah, they don't give it.
That's why the election
should is so simple to me.
Like the Democrats are going to offer
money and republics going to offer jobs
and you see it happening right now it's
like every platform for the Dems on some
level is here's some money. Hey,
we should look into reparations.
Here's some money. Your boy Yang
who's on here. How long were you?
Just give everybody $1,000 here's
some money just giving money, right?
Let's break up Facebook and
the Dah, Dah, Dah. Well,
that's one of the reasons
why for hardworking people,
the Republicans are so attractive.
Even though a lot of people,
they fall into a lower
income community like that,
they're not these rich cats.
They would think there would be looking
to have like big, big business succeed,
but the messages that you roll up your
sleeves and you get to work and that you
work hard, you don't get a
free ride. And they liked that.
And that's also one of the reasons why
people that are Republicans are more
likely to be involved in churches and
a lot of church going organizations
because that's where their community
comes from. And the community support,
instead of getting community
support from the government,
you get community support from local
churches as a good point. Yeah.
So you have your support, you have
your, we all need that man. Yeah.
That's something that really
is missing with atheists.
Yes community and they're miserable.
They're,
I've never met this happy atheists.
It's like they're
vegans. It's like, stop
convincing me that God has don't,
if you believe it, we're good.
You don't need to convince me.
If you are trying to convince me, it's
because you don't believe it. Well,
it's not that they don't believe it,
it's just that they're vibrant.
They're overzealous.
Dude.
What do people who are overzealous or
overcompensating for something, right.
A lot of times,
what do you overcompensating for with God?
Cause you know shit is bigger than you.
Cause you fucking look up sometimes and
you're looking at the stars and you're
like fuck, something's up. I don't know
what it is. I don't know if it's God,
I don't know. If it's aliens, I don't know
what's going on. But you are minuscule.
Yeah. And that's hard for
people to take man. It's like,
well you think that's why they're
really into pushing atheism.
I think it's cause the religion that
they see you so offensively stupid.
I mean, look, there was a funny thing
that happened the other day where it,
Pete Davidson did a joke on SNL,
right about the Catholic Church and the
Catholic Church demanded an apology,
right? We're giving him, yeah,
you're the forgiveness people.
Why do you need an apology?
How bout he made a joke about child
molesting and you guys are the number one
kid fucking organization in the world.
How long can stop worrying about jokes
at paying attention to the fact that you
basically run a kid fucking organization
that also sells Jesus Kff can fucking
factory, bro. That's how it is, man.
And a lot of ways and but at the same
time there's the gray area because they do
a lot of fucking good. Yes. They
say that a lot of people's lives,
they feed a lot of people,
right? So it's like they,
they give people community that
give people a place to connect. Yes.
We're in the most connected time in
history and where the most fucking
disconnected, right? Think about that.
We've got a million friends on Facebook
and all these other things and people
are lonely because we're connected
with electronic devices, connect with,
we're not connected with
life. Right. And, and we're,
and we're connected to outcome,
right. We're connected to hope.
Did this picture I post get
enough likes. Yeah. Right.
That's where they really
fucked people with likes.
Once they figured out how to get people
like supremely addicted to interactions
and exchanges and likes, man, dude,
you know, when like, you know,
movies in the morning you wake up and
he'd smoke a cigarette [inaudible] right?
Like that was what the
movies we watched coming up.
And that was the first thing that the
bad ass or something like that did in the
movie. Wake up, roll over
on to the pack, you know,
whatever it will be looking at your phones
mentions there's going to be some of
that that's going to be what
these characters do. Yup. Yup.
So it's like, what do you,
do you got kids? Do you take,
do you say no? How do you,
how do you teach your kid? I
don't have kids. I don't know.
But like I think about this all the time,
how do I teach my kid to not put his
whole fucking value in the hands of get
them involved in sports? Because you
learn, you learn reality. Reality. Yeah.
You, if you don't get that ball
in the net, it does not score.
You know? There's no points for effort.
Yeah, there's no you don't. It doesn't
work that way.
You got to learn what real life is
and you got to learn that there is,
it's feels uncomfortable to fail,
but that uncomfortable feeling that you
get is fuel and then let your kids fail.
Will you let them fall on their face?
They fall on the first all the time.
My kids do sports. You know, there've
been involved in athletics in some form,
whether it's martial arts or
gymnastics since they were little.
They do things that are difficult. We
do stuff as a family that are difficult.
We do like escape rooms. We play
games, we do things that are hard.
I don't let them win. Yeah.
I mean, my, my little one,
I let her win sometimes and stuff like
we play carnival games against each other
or something like that. I'll
let it, carnival games. Yeah.
Like go to like a circus circus.
Like when I was in Vegas,
I was in Vegas for this thing
that my daughter was doing.
So I took my youngest daughter circus
circus playing these carnival games. Okay.
How let her beat me a bunch of times.
But that's,
we're having fun laughing and being silly,
talking trash to each other too. Yes.
She, high fives means
stuff. It's fun. But uh,
I think there's value in learning that
it sucks to lose because that makes you
reassess like what you did that the
other person did better and how do I beat
them? Yeah. It's like when
we're talking about weed,
but weed making you nervous and
makes you paranoid. Like I like that.
What I like is, look, I'm
entirely too successful. I like,
I like to feel vulnerable. I think
there's a lot of good to that. You know,
like legitimately I liked that
feeling because it makes me, um,
it makes me more connected.
It makes me more humble.
What do you mean you're too successful?
Well,
you can only have so much success in
this life for you start thinking that
you're different than other people.
You know,
it's you thinking that you're
something special. No, he,
look, if you're on a path,
right?
If everybody's on a path and you start
off here and then x amount of years later
your way away, you could
start thinking, oh,
I'm better than all those motherfuckers.
Yeah, but you're not, you're just,
you just have been on this path longer
and you haven't fallen off of it.
You've figured out what you
need to do to stay on that path.
We know a lot of people that were on
the path at one time in their career and
then something happened.
They lost their enthusiasm or their body
wasn't as healthy or whatever the fuck
happened and they dropped off.
I'm still on that path. Why?
Because I figured it out. What does it
keep going? Keep going. Don't be a pussy.
Keep working.
Improve objectively,
analyze your performance.
Look at what you're doing wrong.
Treat everything with respect.
Treat all of your endeavors with
focus and intensity and intention.
Look at what you're doing and
pay attention and do the work.
Do the Goddamn work. Do the writing,
do the performing the, you'll see me,
I'll do four or five sets a night in La
and I'm doing 1520 minutes, half hour.
I'll do an hour here.
I'll go down the ice house.
We'll do an hour ice house and doing
two shows, the Ice House tomorrow night.
And I'm, I'm, I go, whoa. I
go, well, there's no excuses.
I go and now it's like the, to me, the
way I've got it set up, it's great.
My kids go to bed. By the time my
kids are in bed, I leave, you know,
I say goodnight night, tuck them in. I'm
out the door, I'm headed to the club.
I'm home in four hours, you know,
and when I'm, when I'm done,
I get in front of the computer and I
write, I write, I get up in the morning,
I see him off to school, go back to sleep
or I go to the gym, I get things done,
keep moving, got to keep
moving. My job is the task.
It's like my job is,
I'm trying to,
like right now it's most exciting
time for me, uh, in my career arc,
my, uh, my, my comedy arc because
my comedy arc is put out a special,
it's very exciting when
you're putting out a special,
but then the most exciting time is, you
know, my special came out in October.
So then those months afterwards where
it's this mad rush to create a new,
a new hour and solidifying perspectives
and honing material and uncovering new
layers and looking at it and reanalyze
it and stepping back and listening to a
drunk and listening to
it's sober and, and, and,
and smoking weed and going over it again.
And just spending time mashing the keys,
spending time,
looking at the notes that you can type
your stuff, you know? Yeah, yeah. Type.
Yeah.
It's very valuable to be able to type
because you can get out your thoughts way
quicker than you can writing.
Writing makes you remember it better than
you remember it better when you write
it down physically on paper.
So if you look at my notebooks,
I, I'm like a maniac.
I write the same thing over and over and
over again cause I'm just writing down
my sets, running down my bits and the
key parts of the bits so that I have,
I'm solid in my brain,
but my writing in terms of like my most
prolific creation of things that I never
thought of before comes out writing
with a keyboard, writing on a computer.
But can you write how you speak?
Nope, but I don't have to.
So it's just how you come up with gems.
Gems is here and then you flat say form.
Ah, yes, yes, yes, yes. Yeah.
I was going to write a bit about
Geraldo Rivera in the poppy seeds.
I would smoke a joint.
Right now it's sit down and I would
just go Geraldo Rivera with his porn
mustache,
strolling around these trained killers
and Afghanistan wearing his goofy ass
fucking tie.
I wonder how those dudes,
and not as I think of what else to do
is think about strutting around puffing
his chest out,
hanging around.
All these guys have been blowing people's
brains outs for the last six months
protecting America while they're also
simultaneously protecting heroin like hey
on is that when your boy gets shot
protecting a fucking heroin field and it
doesn't even make it into the paper.
And then I'll just start going and going
and going and going and I might type
out a few thousand words
and then when I go back,
I might have two lines or a or a seed.
Then I'll take that seed on stage
and then I'll to see if I could water
that bitch or if it's toxic
and I don't know, you know,
know how long will you give the toxic?
That depends pens on the bits.
Some bits are just juicy right
out of the box. Some bits,
you just start them up and you're like,
oh, we got one kid. Yeah. You know,
and then it's the ones that like,
what about the ones that don't work?
But you know, there's something
there. Oh, you've seen it.
How long will you want pens
on? How, how intense it is.
Depends on what's there for me. Like, uh,
I had this bit about Bruce Jenner.
Like what really happened?
Like with Bruce Jenner,
you know,
and I had to try to figure out how do I
make fun of this guy becoming a woman?
How do I do this? Like, how do I,
how do I figure out how to do this?
And the way to do it for me was to make
fun of myself living with all women
because I have a wife and I have three
daughters and it's like this little all
is feminine energy around me.
And like that they didn't diminish my
manhood so that I had this like that.
I've never been happier. But yeah, I've
never been more of a bitch my life.
And I had this whole long path.
And then it got to, you know,
I've never been more of a bitch in
my life, but I'm telling you this,
I'm not going out like Bruce Jenner.
Boom.
And the whole thing was people were
like, someone's got a fucking sad. I go,
everyone's like, oh, he's a woman trapped
in a man's body. I'm like, maybe, maybe.
Or maybe if you live with crazy bitches
long enough, you fucking, they come off.
And then I,
then I got into this whole bit about the,
the Kardashians becoming like these
gargoyles and hovering over his bed and
talking to him while he's sleeping.
And he's,
if I had to figure out a way to do that
bit right, it took a long time. Yeah.
There's a, I thought that's
something I would love people,
I would love for people to know I do this.
Should I do this show called inside jokes
where I just get comics to come and we
take our most divisive premises, don't
look and we work it out together. And um,
and it'd be so cool to do with you,
man. We'll do it. I'll definitely do it.
Chris rock went through that with his,
probably one of his most famous bit.
His mom's faint. One of his most famous
bits is, I love black people. I hate
that bit is one of his most
popular all the time bits.
He told me he bombed with that for a year.
Yeah. A year. Yeah. Said he couldn't,
he couldn't get it to work because
Chris is a fucking workhorse system.
People don't know about Chris Man.
Like it's a great story that
exposed everything about him.
He was filming his special at the Apollo
in New York and there was an after
party for his own special that he left
so that he could go work on that set at
the strip. Wow. So that's work.
Right. So you got to do, man,
the guy didn't become one of the
biggest hangups of all time by,
it seems like they shouldn't, they
shouldn't kept works cabbies out there.
It makes you tired. Exhausting.
Yeah. Yeah. And I'll get it.
You can jog with him.
It's like he's like our joke
version of the Rock, you know?
You know what I'm saying? Like,
cause he fucking never, never.
It's all private jets,
Jetson hitting the gym and fucking
concerts in front of 50 million people.
It's the same shit man.
Like this isn't an accident once would,
what an is an accident.
They get exposed.
The ones that are faking the funk boy.
That's the reason why Netflix took out
the fucking thumbs up, thumbs down,
you know all that shit.
Remember when they did like you,
cause there was a few of
those specials that look this,
their special needs that
have been on comedy on Hbo.
Youtube is interesting because they
still have this thumbs up, thumbs down,
you know which people do game.
But the reality of that thumbs up,
thumbs down is you get to see what the
fuck people really think. Absolutely.
To a certain extent you think,
I think it's 100% bullshit
at this point it was useful.
But now back to your point that you have,
you have a whole bit about how
many thumbs up and thumbs down.
Have you ever clicked on zero?
Right.
So a certain subset of the population
has thumbs up and thumbs down. It's like,
well it's like yellow
leave comments. Yeah, yeah.
Or write reviews for fucking food.
I think if you were to magical a
bit about that, doe does a good,
a good bit of both. I forget
wake, I don't want to butcher it,
but if something about
like someone left like a,
like a three out of five review and it's
like who the fuck are you like I get if
you loved it or you hated it.
But
to write about this,
some people fancy themselves to
be like foodies and a journalist,
you know,
exploring the subtle nuances of cuisine.
If you're hungry, it's good. It is.
But when you see a guy like Andrew
Zimmerman traveling around the world doing
that or you see Anthony Bordain
or a lot of these people you take,
I want to be like Lens for culture
though, right? It was like,
it was more than just food. It was like,
what does this food say about the people?
Some of the other guy like, like I
mean, I don't know Zimmer, what is it?
The weird food guy.
First of all,
he looks like a salmon and it's just
weird to like just fucking stare at this
guy. Then like it's just
odd when you look at them,
right? Yeah. It's just, I don't just make
it as way up fish ladders trying to get,
he's trying to get all the stream,
I suppose the sand.
I would say a tuna. Okay. He's
got a little tune in him. Hmm.
Handsome fellow. Gorgeous.
Could be on a bill.
Um, anyway. Yeah. I don't
know why the fuck they're
leaving these things, but it's,
you know,
they,
some people want is they invested so
much money in certain things that we're
getting down likes and I was like,
all right.
Like I guess they were doing
it with Starz, right? Was
it stars with Netflix? Yeah.
Yeah.
They pulled the star system too bad.
I had a lot of motherfucking stars pitch.
Yeah.
People are going to watch your people
are going to watch yours regardless.
I think you give them an
add value and added value.
He said there's certain people that
give Netflix the added value and there's
certain people that want the
value from it. It's also,
they're documenting some of the greatest
standup specials in the history of
stand up. There's like the Chappelle
specials, the two recent ones that he did.
They're putting that stuff
out there and they're,
they're doing it in a way where
no one else would do it. Like Hbo,
which was the gold standard
for the longest time. Yeah.
They would never do two Dave
Chappelle specials at the same time.
Netflix is like, okay, we'll do Dave's
like, I got this new shit I want to do.
I'm going to do it in the belly
room at the comedy store. You know,
and Dave was so ridiculous about it.
Dave and I were downstairs. Yeah.
While he was doing this, while he was
filming this, we're downstairs, uh,
or the in the smoking area of the
comic store getting high as fuck. Yeah.
And he was so casual about is like,
hey man,
you want to do it set like you did the
bird? No, no, no. I just want to watch.
I said, no, no. I did three
sets a night. I go, I'm,
I'm just going to chill and hang
out in the back of the room.
But he was so relaxed.
Like during his special being taped,
he's offering me a guest set. He's
like, hey man, I'll do it set. You know,
he still shows up. He'll fly to places
and show up and just do guests sets.
Yeah. I was in Denver. I
come out the green room,
it's Friday night and Chappelle's there
and chapels in the green room and I go
there. He goes, hey Joe. I go,
what are you doing this? Oh Man.
It's felt like coming to Denver. I go,
you want to do a set? It's like, oh yeah,
fuck it. So I bring him up on stage. The
audience is leaving. They're leaving.
Can I come back? It's your pals here.
They're like, what's, yeah. Yeah.
Everybody comes back. He does 40
minutes. It was amazing cause it's,
that's how he's doing it. He's
like, he's doing it for the art.
He's not doing it because
he's making any money.
He did a free 40 minute show for these
people that came there to see me. Yeah.
Fucking loves it and loves it. And he
hits, it's like true with him, man.
He's a perfect example of that.
Just being true.
He'll show up Monday night at the comedy
store in front of 13 people and he'll
go on stage. I'll do a half an
hour in front of 13 people. Yeah.
And he'll drink and he'll smoke cigarettes
and we'll talk shit and laugh at his
own jokes. And everybody has like one
of the most magical experiences as a,
as an audience member you could ever have.
I was young comic in New York and there
was a place called the comedy village,
which was the Boston. Do you
remember? I remember. Sure.
So it became comedy village. When did it
become the village? And it's done now,
but now it's like a Japanese
restaurant. A Japanese restaurant. No.
Got It. Jamie. Cutten. No, but, uh,
there's a, um, uh, in, in this is
young like bark and asking
people to come in off the street.
And how old were you when
you started? A 23, 23.
23. Yeah. And, um,
and Chappelle comes in
and when he gets on stage,
there's probably 13 people in the crowd,
right.
And the fucking word gets out and you
just see people start slowly graphs like
goldfish.
You know what I mean?
When they could send some little
or ducks or something like that,
when they send some breads coming in
the pond and the place was packed within
like 20 minutes. Wow. Outside, it was
just everybody texting their friend.
Oh my God. Chappelle's here, here to
do so crazy. And he did six hours, Bro.
One real dude.
And were there were there were girls like
falling asleep or something like maybe
four hours, 24 hours, something like that.
It was one of these known ones
landed it. It was jazz. Right?
It wasn't like, it wasn't like I'm doing
bits and I'm murdering the whole time.
He has this ability to make the audience
comfortable intention so that it is not
anxiety inducing.
Right.
What what he can do is talk to you for
five minutes straight without a punchline.
But as an audience member, you're
not going, oh my God is this guy,
is this guy not funny
when he was,
he was doing that for a while and
where he wasn't doing scheduled shows,
all he was doing was these pop ends.
And not only that,
but he brought a fucking speaker and set
up a microphone in the park in Seattle,
outdoor, outdoor. You know he did that
early on. Yeah, I was there. I watched it,
watched them do it in much New York or not
do it in Montreal.
We did a set together at club soda and
as we got outside we went outside and
Dave just said
gather round,
people gather it.
And he started doing stand up to people
in the street and they were like,
what in the fuck? He was probably like
20 so do you know William Stephenson?
Yeah. Comic rest, some shorts and a,
he was one of the original like comedy
and the park guys doing stand up.
Charlie Barnett, Barnett, Barnett
and Dave would go with those doubts.
Yup. Yup. And like,
can you imagine a more hostile environment
for stand up the New York City Park,
New York City Park.
You compete with guys doing fun flips
over Swedish tourists and then there's a
guy just with jokes hand hanging on is
you know, handling his own. It's like,
then you put him on a stage with lights
and fucking Mike and a see and some
cigarettes. Yep, that's,
yeah, it's trength training.
It's like running with weights on,
so how do what the question
is how do we do that?
Like how do you find that
the more successful you get
when you have people that
are coming to see you no matter what?
Where do we get our strength training?
Where do we get smoke weed.
Paranoid. That's what I'm
saying, Bro. I feel vulnerable.
That was going to feel scared.
Filled nervous a lot.
I like it. I really do. I do it all.
Like I joke around on stage about how
I take edibles when I go to the airport
because I like feeling, I want to know
what the fuck's really bothering me,
but it's really true. I really do do
that. I take an edible when I fly.
It's just like a freak out because you're
too comfortable with this. Weird, yeah.
I get something out of that freaking out.
Like I'll find out where the holes in my
game or I find out where my mental game
is lacking,
what's really bothering me and then things
that freaked me out that I don't like
about myself. I've work on them. I
fix them. I visit the wizard. You,
you got to visit the wizard.
I wonder if this comes from having
fighting background because the one thing
about fighting is if you
have a hole in your game,
it's exposed in the most brutal
way. Right. Everything else in life,
you can ignore the holes in your
game. Yup. You can just be like, oh,
I'm not a bad storyteller any. They were
just busy. I concentrate on my strengths.
Yeah. Yeah. Boxing or fight,
whatever it is. It's just like,
I better keep my hand up.
Yep.
You better patch up those holes, bitch.
Maybe that's what it is with standing on.
I think that's what it is with me.
I'm just, that's my formula. I mean,
I don't recommend it to everybody
because everybody doesn't have the same
personality. Like you might not
have those same deficiencies.
Like it actually might be psychologically
damaging to some people to get as high
as I get.
You know,
like it might fuck with your head too
much where you don't come back from it.
I come back like a nicer person,
but I'm in the same throws of fucking
agony that a lot of people are when they
get to high.
So you're purposely yeah.
Fucking your shock and my system.
Yeah.
A purposely freak myself the fuck out.
And you don't think you'd be able to
create without it? Oh, definitely could,
but not as good.
I don't know if I can as good, but
I know it works. I like doing it.
I liked doing it because uh,
I always benefit from it.
I feel like I come back from
those little paranoid journeys.
I go a little bit of a better person
and I think it's been responsible along
with other psychedelics
and becoming a father.
All those things may be a better person.
Maybe a nicer person,
maybe more compassionate, more
understanding, more friendly. Well, yeah.
More understanding is the big
one. More. More just I get it.
I don't want to be confident all the time.
I don't want to always be successful,
like,
you know what I mean?
This is like good people listening right
now that like that's all they want,
but they haven't experienced the
other side of the coin. Yeah.
Do you know what I'm saying?
But when people get too confident and
then they have an audience, right.
If you have an audience, that's part of
the problem is, and we've all seen this,
when comics become really successful,
they work to their own crowd
and they don't do sets. Yeah.
They don't do a set like I'll do it.
The store you'll do where there's like 10
people on the line. Right, right, right.
Deleah yeah. They might be
there to see a fucking Eliza.
They might not be there to see me at all.
Right.
But I want to hit those mother fuckers.
I want to hit them hard and they want
to go, oh, look at this meathead.
You know this fucking champ. Look and
dude, what's he going to say? You're like,
yeah, you can't be smart and
funny. You can't be interesting.
Whatever their biases is. I got to
figure out a way to sue that over.
And the best way to do that is you got
to perform and hostile environments
occasionally. Yeah. You know that this
is all so critical, man. So critical.
Have good openers like up killers, kill.
Bring murderers with me on the road.
Only way to do it. I bring Joey d as
in the road with me, man, I brought,
brought Joey d as in the road for years.
I would tell people they would get
white in the face. They'd be like, what?
The who opened for you in Dallas? Oh,
Diaz did. Joey, do you get nervous?
Like what?
Joey Diaz in front of 6,000 people,
Joey Diaz Open for you and
you ain't seen murderer.
You Ain't seen Joey Diaz at the Chicago
theater for a 3,700 people in the
fucking lights are dimming the lights or
fucking crushing so hard.
People are falling down there.
They're in pain and pain. Yeah.
You've never seen him live.
Ooh, I really wanted to, when I was
in la, I set it up Halloween town for,
I got to go tomorrow. You'll even a,
yeah. Is he around tonight? I'll find out.
I would love to. He might be. He might
be doing a set at the store tonight.
I'll ask him, man. There is. He's
the goat and my opinion. Really? Yup.
Whoa. I never seen anybody
funnier. Whoa. He's,
he might not be the best writer.
He might not have the most
consistently crafted hours,
but it terms of the highest highs,
that motherfucker breaks through the mag
fear and he wiggles out into the outer
atmosphere of space.
Like no one he hits these
highs were like comics,
comics work are crying,
like holding your stomach crying and
he's screaming and yelling and it's like,
you ain't seen nothing like it,
man. He was onstage. I wrote about,
I put it on my Instagram the other day.
He crushed so hard and I can't
even say what he was talking.
He
crush is so hard and it was
such controversial material.
So unapologetic. Good Push. Yeah.
And He, at one point in time, people
were like, what the fuck? He goes,
what do you want from me? I'm almost
dead. Because they got to give a fuck.
And people were dying. I mean dying. I
don't think there's ever been a person.
I've seen everybody, dude, I seen
everybody from rock to Chappelle,
the Louis C,
k I watched Sam Kinison when he was alive.
I saw bill Hicks when he was
alive. I opened up, I'm a follow,
I had a follow up prior when he was dying,
when it looked for five weeks in a row,
but I saw a prior live.
I've seen everybody live. I saw
Martin Lawrence and he's in his prime.
People forget how funny Martin
Lawrence was. He was destroyed.
I saw him back when he was
wearing leather jumpsuits,
who'd gone still realize man was leather
jumpsuits and smash smash and the
struggle on after him.
But I never saw anybody like Joey.
Joey's on another level. Who
is, who's your toughest follow
Joey? Without a doubt. Yeah, man.
You gotta. You gotta ride that wave.
But that's what's good
about it is like if you're,
if you're funny and you're working on your
stuff and you're and you enjoy comedy,
you go on stage already laughing,
so you go on stage already in a
good mood. That's, that's what's up.
Like part of the being a tough,
tough follow is two things. One,
you're used to going on after scrubs
and there's a lot of guys that are good
comics,
but they'd like to bring scrubs in the
road with them and then they get settled
in in that easy sort of, I'm
going to see the show. Exactly.
There's a lot of guys that do that, man.
They'll take guys on the road with them.
They're really or barely professionals
and these guys are filling theaters and
they're bringing week acts and they forced
us audience to sit through a half an
hour of bullshit before they go onstage
and then there's guys who don't do it
like that. They just look, I don't know.
I don't know who was doing it
that way before I was doing it,
but my thought was I like, if a guy
makes me nervous when I go on after him,
that's going to make me ramp it up like
I don't, I don't walk on stage cold.
I'm backstage throwing punches
and doing jumping jacks.
I'm doing breathing exercises.
When I come on stage I'm fucking guns
blazing and that that's if you go on after
Joey Diaz when he hits that crescendo,
it better be ready.
When you came into the store,
I remember I was about to
ask you something and you
were on the wall and then
you just folded in half and
touch your toes and I was like,
what the fuck is going? I could barely
touch my ankles was like, all right,
this is ritual. I'm going to let
him do his thing. Listen Up. Yeah.
I get loose and I figured out that over
the over time you can just walk on stage
and everything would be fine or you walk
on stage with a already you've got some
intention.
Yeah.
I guess sometimes I got to remind myself
of certain things to get up there.
And the most important thing I learned
is reminding myself that this crowd
wasn't at the last show.
Yeah.
Like you sometimes you can
take that energy from the
early show and we were just
bottling it and you're like, oh, I
got this. Let's go, let's just walk.
They weren't there, so you can't
do that. Can't do that. Yeah.
You gotta you gotta always, always
appreciate the audience's attention span.
And that's something that I've really
learned from Boston and Boston.
It's cold as fuck.
The women aren't the prettiest in the
world and people are angry and they got to
work in the morning.
I'd be ready Tuesday night I did this,
I did this thing and
it never got picked up.
And I put it out as part of
this like a series. Essentially.
It's like I emulated Bourdain's thing.
I want to look at a city through the lens
of comedy instead of food. Right. And I,
the first city I picked was Boston, cause
all my favorite comics are from Boston.
And I'm like, why the fuck has
this city produced so much funny?
What does much immigrant people, is
that it? Yeah, so it landed there.
And what type of funny Patrice
O'neal's Michael, right? Yup.
So it's like put Patrice,
but he's one of the goats for sure.
You can go bill Murray one liners
Berg late, whatever. Steven,
Steven Wright.
Conan is from the area.
I think we're talking about
all different types of comedy.
Silvermans I think from New Hampshire
or something like that. Right.
But like there's something about the
region that no matter what style you see,
you funny come from here where
you're from. An area of what?
What was it? Newton. Newton.
Boston. You're actually, yeah,
so I was talking to in Boston.
I knew you started
there, but I didn't know if
you were from the city or what.
He was born in New Jersey,
but a,
I lived all throughout my high school
years and everything. I lived in Boston,
so it's like what the, what
the fuck is it about? This city
was cold as fuck. It's cold.
Yeah, but something there.
It's too cold. I need to be warming
up to like talk to people. Yeah.
It needs to be warm enough
for we go outside also,
well you know it's a scene. It's like
a scene has to be established to,
because Boston does not have the scene
it used to have in the 80s right.
But la has a better scene than ever and
scenes are fluid. They come and they go,
you know like Denver has a scene and they
have a scene because of Wendy who owns
the comic con.
But there's,
there's different places that have scenes
and Barry Crimmins and Lenny Clarke
and Steve Sweeney and dawn Gavin and all
those guys that were part of the Ding
Ho in the 1980s and
Steve was on my podcast.
And those guys created a
scene and through that scene,
the end,
because they were all competing with
each other for spots on the tonight show
and all these different little
venues, they, they created a,
a monster dynamic where all these young
guys were coming up following these
killers. And I was very fortunate
to be one of those guys.
And that's why I wanted to talk to Steve
and tell him that on the show is like I
saw that fucking guy,
I saw that guy murder
murder to the Pullman. No,
and nobody was watching in terms
of like the national audience,
it was just Boston,
but he would go on stage at Nick's comedy
stop and level the crowd level that
like a fucking hydrogen bomb dropped
in the middle of the room. Just boom.
So you,
so you learn what killing is like.
I feel like one of the toughest
things about the alternative scenes,
and I'm not knocking this,
they're the comedy,
but the litmus test for
murdering is different. You know,
when I was coming up in New York and I
had to follow recipes, Mike Destefano,
you know, Greer Barnes guys that
maybe are not household names but
did Greer's a beast.
Greer and I did shows together.
We did it colleges together right
back on the road. Wave in the 90s.
If, um, if you want to know, at least for
me, if you want to know what Chappelle is,
Chappelle is Tony Woods and Greer,
he is a,
Tony was another beast,
but Tony is unfathomable.
But like he's the Gremlin that
popped off of both of their backs.
Like if you could mold them together,
like everything that is amazing
about Tony and amazing about Greer.
Well, I mean, that's how it is with
music. That's how it is with everything.
We need each other.
You know?
That's why when I see a guy
like you coming up and I'm
like, Ooh, good. Thank you.
I'm happy you're around. Um,
I like it. I like comedy.
If I stopped doing comedy tomorrow,
I want more comedy to watch.
I love La. I love laughing. Yeah. I
like, that's why I tell you I've sit,
I sit down and watch Joey Diaz. I
fucking love Comma here, you know?
And but thinking about Joey is, Joey
has new material all the fucking time.
You go see Joey
now and you see him four months from
now, you'll see a whole new set. Yeah.
I got to see Joey while I'm out here.
He's the best man. I'm telling you.
If he's doing his watch him, I'm going
to try to see if he's where's? Yeah.
You guys have a show? I
think so. Maybe I'll go.
Maybe I'll run over and see comedy
store. What time? Eight o'clock show. Oh,
he's on the eight o'clock show. Yeah.
Well, have you got the eight o'clock show?
It'd be on later. I'll find
out when he's up. Yeah.
Who shows tonight at the comedy store
before eight o'clock version
of the scholars or show?
Oh my on that tonight at
10 o'clock I think I am.
That's what it said. Okay. Oh
yeah. I guess I am. All right.
I forgot. Well, I know I have a set
of the store. I guess I have to,
yeah, I just got to see him. Let's wrap
this up. Andrew. Thank you. Here we go.
Scour stone. Oh, look at that. I'm
on that. Okay. Hmm. Interesting.
All right, beautiful. Cool. All right,
fuckers. That's it. Tell everybody
where to find your shit. Oh, a youtube,
youtube.com/the Andrew Shelton.
You check out the Andrew Schultz,
Andrew shells was taken. No t in shells
and then a Twitter and Instagram,
just Andrew Schultz. And um, yeah, check
out the special man if you love it.
And you know, if you like it, share with
your friends, that'd be awesome. If not,
you know, I appreciate you
even just watching, so thank
you so much for having me,
man. This was great confidence for
being you. I appreciate it. Love it.
Love seeing guys like you come up. I
appreciate you. All right. Bye everybody.
We'll see you soon.
Okay.